all right we're going live in 10 seconds
stand by
are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
[Music]
awesome folks uh it's good to have you
on with us today's what episode number
153 i have my good friend matt walton in
the house
my man
uh mad you and i go back a few years
right couple years ago in dallas i
interviewed you uh we met through a
mutual acquaintance guy named paul
feldman he's also a classmate of mine in
high school
insurance news insurance news respect i
know paul real quick
it's newsnet yeah yeah yeah and um when
the i used to make a lot of money in
commercials when all that money sort of
started going to the influencers instead
i reached out to some of my friends who
were successful and said hey you
probably need some video content and
paul was one of the guys who's like hell
yeah i do and we started making stuff
for his magazine
among that content was an interview with
patrick bett david
and we became fast friends then we kept
in touch over social media and you know
we we have a lot of the same background
you know scrappy entrepreneurs and so we
you know we have a kindred spirit so
thanks for having me no question about
it man you know matt for some of you
guys that don't know matt matt's an
actor i i think that's the best way
you've done broadway you've done
hollywood uh if you can pull up his uh i
am if you watch irish man he was an
irish man he's been in uh
uh a money monster i think that's what
the uh clooney is that what jody foster
directed jody foster would purge which
was purge election year you were in that
but you know what i want you to pull up
i want you to pull up go to go just go
to uh type his name and just go to
images and it's unfair i mean look at
this gentleman if you're watching with
your wives just tell your wives to look
away right click on that first go go to
that one look at how sexy this guy it's
just too much bro that was in the rain
too yeah go go to the other one with the
old one the the one right there let me
see which one it is go with the perfect
white teeth go to the perfect white
teeth so today look at this this makes
no sense who do people tell you look
like the most what do you get
like dylan mcdermott or derma rooney
they always get the dylan the the the
scottish
sometimes i would get got bakula
quantum leap quantum leaps got that who
were you going to say yeah somebody mine
or i don't know i'm i mean scott bakula
uh
could be a guy
i could never tell the difference
between dylan mcdermott and
rooney neither could anyone else right
that was like the running joke so you
know you know what's crazy we've been
we've been uh uh we've been trying to do
this for a while to get mad on yeah and
i'm excited for today because matt one
thing i like about you is
you've been in hollywood you you've done
a lot of work with pretty much everybody
you don't work with a lot of people you
just you just did something with uh uh
mcgregor yeah that's right i mean you've
done you done stuff with the biggest
names
but uh also at the same time you got
some strong opinions as well politically
and when i follow your twitter i
i don't miss your tweets i just want you
to see what the hell this guy's gonna
say next and it's entertaining but you
talk a lot of [ __ ] yeah it gets me in
trouble sometimes yeah but i can imagine
that but uh yeah i said listen why don't
we why don't we figure something out
here to get you on the podcast by the
way folks for some of you guys that are
listening today today we're doing an old
school format of a podcast my goal is to
do the following been talking about this
a lot
this is the problem when you have a very
good booker okay
it's it works uh uh uh you know both
ways he's booked this out for how long i
think we're booked on july or august
we've got several dates in july but
every once in a while we just want to
talk current events we're trying to get
it in my schedule right now to put one
every week no matter what we're talking
current events we got a lot of topics to
go through fyi guess who we have
tomorrow on the podcast the great some
call them the goat i asked this question
yesterday on twitter name me the
greatest ufc fighter of all time you
know what a lot of people said they said
gsp tomorrow on the podcast will be
george saint-pierre in the flesh right
here talking there's a lot of talk about
him
with khabib there's a lot of things that
are you know coming up lately so i can't
wait to do that interview but again
that's a pie product of having a guy
that's booking us non-stop rob we're
proud of you having said that here's
some of the topics we're going to get
into so
i've been watching this uh johnny depp
and amber heard you know back and forth
right and you know what's the biggest
question i ask myself is the following
here's what i asked man i want to get
your input on this i asked myself okay
both of these guys act for a living
right i mean both of their jobs is to
convince me and feel the pain of what
they're going through right so who do
you believe do you believe johnny do you
believe her she's been crying the last
couple days because it's been her turn i
think and he was telling his stories and
having fun but both ways i want to kind
of get your input on that uh row v
weight versus which is uh you know
obviously something everyone's talking
about right now from the left from the
right everybody which i have some bad
news for you on that end that's uh
i think it's going to hurt your feelings
but you're going to be okay with that
i'm going to
increased half a point folks let me say
this one more time half a point biggest
hike in two decades and i'm gonna
explain to you what this means to you
we'll get some feedback from both folks
here on how this affects who biden
proposes largest tax increase since lbj
biden seemingly unaware he is uh was
ever a senator in the latest gaffe
and then we have a joe biden's approval
underwater 60 disapprove of handling of
inflation and then we have buffett's uh
question was asked about nuclear weapons
which was very interesting he says so
how one of the uh uh investors who owns
the share says how concerned are you
about a nuclear war and his answer was a
coin flip meaning it can happen any
minute for a guy like that worth a
hundred billy to say it's a coin flip
we'll be curious to know what he has to
say about that charlie munger's still
putting a lot of hate on bitcoin
trade deficit source for the first time
over 100 billion dollars uh this is a
first time ever
uh college graduates are overestimating
their salaries um they'll start out at
50k but you should see what they think
they should earn when they come out of
college musk has just created a bunch of
stuff that we got to talk about his call
out of a
aoc what he said he's gonna do to nbc
the way he slammed nbc was maybe
i i it's just did you see how he slammed
nbc
he tortured them i mean on twitter
and then uh you know he's thinking about
taking public again three years from now
i got some conversations there i can
tell you guys about what call i got
yesterday uh bill maher twitter has a
complete lack of self-awareness about
their own problem they have failed he's
not talking about elon musk twitter he's
talking about the old twitter and then
we got biden officials want musk to
bring trump's crazy back onto it which
is crazy then obviously amber heard and
a few other things that's going on and
we have to cover the story with our
friend dave chappelle who dave chappelle
i say we start off with that story dave
chappelle okay dave chappelle did you
see the video or no see what happened oh
yeah okay are we allowed to play that
i'm sure we can because it's a tweet
um
crazy thing on what happened here with
dave chappelle what page are we on let
me see what page tell me what page run
up that's the bottom of page six okay
all right here we go dave chappelle's
story police arrest suspect
and on stage attack of dave chappelle
rep calls incident unsettling this is a
usa today's story police have arrested a
suspect an onstage attack of de chapel
at the hollywood bowl in los angeles uh
tuesday during a netflix is a joke
festival an audience members stormed the
stage as chappelle 48 was exiting
the stage after performance lunging at
him and tackle him to the ground
according to the press release from the
la police department chappelle refuses
to allow last night's incentive to
overshadow the magic of his historic
moment the comedian's rep karla simpson
in a statement wednesday statement
wednesday start the day smarter get all
the news you need in your inbox each
morning dave chappelle celebrated four
nights of comedy and music
setting record-breaking sales for a
comedian at the hollywood bowl sim said
as unfortunate and unsettling as the
incident was
chappelle went on with the show sim said
the venue security detained 23 year old
isaiah lee lapd officer rosario
cervantes told usa today wednesday uh
they arrested uh lee chappelle was not
injured lee was taken to the hospital
with minor injuries minor injuries have
you seen the guy's shoulder there's
nothing minor about that lee is being
held on thirty thousand dollar bond
according to the release matt what are
your thoughts about what happened here
well they roughed them up pretty good
didn't they um well of course everybody
immediately thinks this is uh you know
uh a result of what will smith did at
the oscars yeah he just set a precedent
yeah you can attack comedians on stage
but do we have a motive for why this guy
went up there as he said what his uh
what why he wanted to attack dave
chappelle was it something dave
chappelle said or was he just trying to
so
so there was a there was a story first
of all this is not a good picture show
the video first so the audience can see
what happened most people have seen it
yeah this dude got roughed yeah yeah you
see his arm yeah his arm is bent the
complete other way he was on backwards
yeah yeah can you show that video first
one second okay clearly security was
beefed up in a big way
apparently it was this jamie foxx that
came to the rest jamie foxx in a cowboy
bust an arm
here we go
look at the guy's arm do you see the
guy's arm his arm your arms facing like
the other way look at that his elbow is
out oh my god yeah that arm right so
you bring up a good point what was this
guy's motive yeah yeah we don't know
dude you know
people are feeling very comfortable
running up on celebrities days i'm not
sure if it's the will smith is if is it
art imitating life life imitating art
you're an actor this is something that
you probably deal with but this reminds
me of like the guy who felt
like he could
feel very comfortable talking [ __ ] to
mike tyson how'd that work out for that
guy right get the living crap kicked out
of him now there might be a lawsuit
pending but it's there's almost like
blurred lines well you know that's a
result of social media that's just what
i was going to say like all through the
pandemic all these musicians are playing
guitar inside their houses i'm like i
don't want to see inside your house i
want there to be a wall of mystery
between me and the artist you know what
i mean and social media has completely
knocked that down it used to be you know
in the case of like soap opera actors
and whatnot if you're i think uh you're
one of your last guests spoke a little
bit about this
um jason i think it was
when you're in somebody's living room
every single day on television the human
body and brain cannot distinguish
between
a relative and a person on tv we haven't
evolved past that yet so it really feels
like you know that person because
they're in your home they're literally
versus being in a movie theater
watching tv and seeing a movie are two
different that was ethan's supply that
he brought that up that's right that's
right um and so this may be you know
instagram and everybody doing things
from their homes and
you know uh celebrities being literally
reachable by through social media this
may have something to do with it or it
could just be this guy wanted you know
his five minutes of fame and who better
to attack than the one of the best
comedians alive i don't know
i just found this link i'm gonna send it
to you tyler to pull it up very
interesting so this guy's apparently a
rapper is what he is uh
so he's a rapper in 2020 he did a song
uh about chappelle
and he also said trump is my president
leave him alone in a rap song so pull up
the link so i'm actually curious now hey
did you see chris rock right there walk
up on stage yeah look at that yeah chris
rock sick was that
by the way you don't have to do that i
mean listen chris that's like a perfect
opportunity for him to get up there but
just so you guys know all of these
events that chris rock is at it's
preparing them to get a 100 million
dollar netflix special in the next few
months and i'm promising you they're
working on something right now go ahead
you were going to say something no this
guy's 23 years old
um
so he's only been born and raised on
social media right since going up since
uh
social media has been what really ten
years strong maybe a little bit longer
with facebook but i'm talking like the
instagrams of the world 10 years strong
so that's all he's ever known but matt
you touched on something the blurred
lines between
it used to be a very clear distinction
between that as a celebrity they're on
stage that is who we watch
and i'm just a regular old person
watching now i don't know you touched on
because it's coveted lockdowns homes on
your phone like all these blurred lines
of like yeah i could just i could just
roll up on mike tyson and talk [ __ ]
right i could just run up on stage with
dave chappelle i'm a rapper i've got a
social media i'm a person i'm famous i'm
famous too it's like buddy there are
clear distinctions between a mike tyson
and a dave chappelle and your clown ass
well the difference between these two
things tyson in this case i mean this
guy attacked him with a knife this is
obviously some kind of
you know
beef the guy had with chappelle and he
wanted to you know
stick him but it was a mentality this
was a fake knife was it this is now it
was it was it was a fake big gun with a
knife within it something like that yeah
so if you look at the picture right
there that's lapd hq and the rest has
been an innocent where comedian was
attacked while on tv
was attacked
not they're not even naming the comedian
and a comedian was attacked while on
stage at hollywood bowl isaiah lee was
charged with assault with a deadly
weapon and bayless said 30 000 so if you
go a little lower
and
you'll see what he says if you go a
little lower that's the clip go below
the video and it says no i think above
that yeah go above that above that right
there so a little higher little high
okay least song
that is specifically titled dave
chappelle was released in 2020 it's on
that song where lee wraps laugh at you
uh uh
yeah as a joke
and then lee has another song defending
former president donald trump with lyric
included mega my
n-word
uh an open-ended question why is
everybody always hating on my president
interesting and then normal tv
if you go a little lower said joe behar
and sunny helps them blame trump for
dave chappelle getting attacked on stage
which is obviously it's of course
trump's fault right they claim he got
into the minds of the entire population
didn't happen before behar insisted
sonia but i think trump unleashed some
incivility in our country there you have
it
um
by the way do you think this is going to
become a movement and more of this
stuff's going to happen like do you
think somebody's looking out there
saying this is a playbook i'm going to
do this as well
100
i mean
and i'm going to the like look i've been
pretty clear i didn't think that the the
what the will smith slap represented was
way worse than the actual slap a man
slapped another man chris rock took it
like a g
said all right i'll leave jade as okay
cool
um but just imagine
if this guy who actually brought a knife
on stage legitimately stabbed dave
chappelle and dave chappelle was in the
hospital now because dave chappelle is
very quick to joke hey thanks we got
jamie foxx here with a cowboy hat
everyone needs a jimmy imagine if dave
chappelle was in the hospital right now
the overall sentiment in the country
would be like holy [ __ ] you brought up
the will smith thing right
that's obviously what came to came to
mind a person rushed the stage and and
attacked a
comedian or a celebrity or an icon but
imagine if chappelle is actually in the
hospital now or god forbid imagine if he
died what would the mood of the entire
country be would everyone be on pause
and be like what the hell is happening
right now guys what is happening right
now no thank god dave chappelle is okay
but this guy had a legitimate knife
imagine if it was a gun right and he
just boom shot him and that's how dave
chappelle went out it's a very very
scary situation yeah so a couple of
things goes to i think about number one
how the hell
did that guy get in there with the gun
and the knife that's number one so
security is one to blame what kind of
security do you have with all these
celebrities being there like what are
you thinking with security that's the
accountability yeah so number one
accountability to me is who put this
thing together who was your security
let's hold the security accountable on
how they got in what was the
infrastructure for somebody like that to
get in number two you know how in
9 11 happened tsa comes right after 9 11
in november we have tsa right two months
after 9 11 we have tsa but back in the
days you can just go hey
hey mom she comes out of the gate and
you see her at the gate people would
forget that that you could literally go
to someone's gate just greet them
afterwards 20 years ago my grandma would
come out meet me off the plane when i
was a kid 12 years old and that event
like this changes so you're you got a
good point there now think about it this
way how much different would this
experience be
if
uh talent now said you know how back in
the days van halen would say here's how
we'll do it this is what we want in our
contract if you don't have this we won't
show up and they used to say they had
this thing with the m ms that they
wanted specific types of m ms and
multiple times if you didn't follow the
contract to the t they would leave
because they said you didn't follow our
contract and you're still liable to pay
us so they had a contract now imagine if
comedians say hey i won't perform until
you put a fence up or you put something
up that i feel safer imagine we get to
that point okay now if a comedian asks
for that say first comedian asks for
that that's what i want to do i don't
feel safe the craziness that's going on
here's what i expect
then that creates a trend so that
becomes the next tsa of what happened
after 9 11. thank god nothing happened
here but you have the guy that pulls up
to tyson you have the guy that pulls up
to him you have the guy that's
and fyi
dave chappelle has
a crew around him and they destroyed him
that guy's lucky he wasn't beat to death
he's lucky he's not beat to that but
there's a part there's a part that's
actually good that that happened to set
the tone for everybody else however
how many people have chapelle size of
entourage
not many nobody there's a younger
comedian that's getting up so you know
how you go to comedy and some guy takes
a shot at she's like oh
who are you you look like your middle
eastern let me guess you have a 750 bmw
parked outside right and you have a lot
of money odds are that car is stolen
papa these comedians say these types of
jokes yeah and i was like you know what
if will's me up i'm gonna get up and
then i'm gonna go out and so then this
younger comedian that's coming up it's
like dude i'm just role playing with the
guests that are here now he gets
something happening to him so he doesn't
have that kind of protection he doesn't
have a big entourage she's coming up so
bigger guy may be protected but the
younger guy coming up may not be
protected so the games change a little
bit i'm very curious you know what these
bigger comedy clubs are going to do to
make their comedians feel safe but i i
would make the argument that somebody
that's not as big as chappelle doesn't
have a reason to be gone after like the
younger guy who's just coming up i mean
if you listen i think this is a one-off
people want to go after chappelle
because he's a lightning rod right he's
always in the news if you're a young
comedian and you're going to this guy's
show you're not going to beat him up
you're going there to laugh you know
what i mean i hope you're right yeah and
yes i don't necessarily disagree with
what adam's saying but i think there's
so much to be said for what you said pat
that that this guy got the snot beat out
of him yeah like he's lucky he wasn't
beaten well listen that's what happens
in life sometimes yeah if if people see
this and they think about going up on
stage and then they look at this guy i
think they're gonna think twice but i
also think that my mind's going
someplace else with this
it's making it about yourself when it
has nothing to do with you this reminds
me of like the streakers who come on uh
run on the field during the super bowl
or during uh the world cup
uh this guy you know steve will do it or
whatever the uh what the elk boys or
whatever they did it wasn't that guy who
did the super bowl thing one of those
guys but you're making it about yourself
you know that there's a lot of eyes on
you
drawing attention you're saying this is
my time i have an opportunity to get my
name in the news i have an opportunity
to put myself into the atmosphere that
all the eyeballs are looking at me and
you're making it about yourself it's ego
driven and the lines are blurred because
you're you have a public profile now
that's a whole other thing don't get me
started on when you go onto someone's
instagram profile and it's public figure
yeah it's like buddy like unless you're
a famous actor famous politician you are
not a public figure i'm sorry but this
mentality this is my biggest concern
this mentality that like i deserve the
eyeballs dude dave chappelle deserves
the eyeballs he's the greatest comedian
living right now in my opinion and going
on for a while okay so yeah the guy you
know go ahead yeah to joy behar's point
uh trump did not bring in incivility
incivility had been here a long time
trump had been in civil for a very long
time you know i used to work for the guy
i know how uncivil he's always been uh
the culture has been shifting toward
incivility and this me me me me
narcissism for a very long time and it's
exacerbated
constantly and it just grows
exponentially each year i find uh this
this case in particular this guy seemed
batshit crazy had a grudge wanted to
hurt dave chappelle in front of
everybody okay that's different uh
that's a little different than what will
smith did
but i also think what's going to end up
happening is comedy is probably going to
change which is the biggest tragedy of
all because comedians are the last
truth-tellers we have you can't tell a
joke without truth in it it's not funny
otherwise and i think comedians are
going to start to adjust their sets
to not offend and to make sure that
stuff like this doesn't happen
particularly if they don't have an
entourage like chappelle that's probably
and that's the biggest danger of all
right let's talk about it with yeah tony
hinchcliffe yeah that's not that's not
we need we need those guys to stay loose
real quick you uh you get up on stage
every so often you have your events you
speak let's say something like this
happens to you not to this extent but
some guy bum rushes you on stage what is
what's your response
but you have to it's happened and it's
gonna happen that's not something like
bush is on stage talking with another
you know prime minister or president
guys throws two shoes out together you
know so it's not moments of that yeah
yeah so you have to know this is not a
new thing you know the guy who went
after you know president uh uh you know
had an infatuation for michelle pfeiffer
she would you i was doing it because i
wanted to impress michelle because you
don't you don't know people's motives
this whole thing we did with the event
last couple days right here's what we
don't know we don't know the guy's real
story we don't know what lee is telling
us isaiah lee guy we don't know what
he's telling himself we don't know
what's in his brain and that's not the
truth but it's his truth right to him
that's the reality of what's going on
you don't know what these guys are
telling themselves but i don't think
it's a new thing i don't think it's been
uh
it just started happening like a you
know two weeks ago it's like the tyson
thing like you mentioned it earlier
somebody went up to tyson with a gun and
what does he do he talks the guy down
and gives him a hug like like you say
man this happens all the time it's just
this gets national headlines yeah the
only difference is the only difference
is
if
if
they do something like that and hurt a
guy size of
chappelle with his kind of a notoriety
shit's going to change very quickly so
that's the one thing they have to
realize shows are going to change
format's going to change security is
going to change everything's going to
change so just think about having to
stand in line for four hours to get in
how annoying is it to go to a show
imagine waiting for four hours we had
president bush at one of our events what
was it three years ago four years ago
right so we've been working on you know
we invited him and we invited obama
obama doesn't do anything in august our
events are always in august and bush
said i'll make it so he came to the
event do you know we had to have a
hundred secret service agents we had to
have security where what do you call a
metal detectors everywhere we had to
invest that money and have it everywhere
to come in they had meetings with us
they had meetings with our crew they had
meetings with people that are on the
inside everybody had a yellow sticker
that you kind of knew you're trained by
secret service to know that for the next
four days while the president's coming
they were so fully prepared for it right
things are going to escalate when things
like this happen i just don't think
that's the last event that we're going
to hear about i think it's going to you
hit the nail on the head with the 911
reference you said that you know 9 11
happened september boom couple months
later in november tsa okay so it's weird
that the hollywood bowl didn't have
metal detectors i think they would the
hollywood bowl under you know i mean but
it will is my point now god forbid dave
chappelle's in the hospital some stab
wounds
boom the tsa reference becomes all too
real into the hollywood until but think
about it we used to just go into into
arenas into theaters yeah walk right in
get your seat right now you're getting
covet-tested you're going through metal
detectors they're patting you down
it takes unfortunately a freaking
tragedy a 911-esque horrible tragedy
dave chappelle god forbid getting
stabbed tragedy for
venues to be like dude that we're not
gonna take the risk right and that's
just what happened yeah i mean again i i
okay if you were to vote do you think
we're gonna hear another story in the
next 30 60 90 days
no doubt no doubt about it i agree i
think it's going to be 30 60 90 days and
i think
uh if i'm the guy that's putting events
together this is an opportunity for me
to say hey dave let me tell you what our
format's going to be for you to feel
protected okay so when i had kobe bryant
at our event
uh five thousand people rushed the stage
okay you can see this on video and kobe
sitting right next to me like what the
hell is going on right
and right there i had security standing
in the front okay
we had were you you were at that event
right okay i had security standing right
out the front and i had to get up and i
asked these guys everybody's got to sit
or else i'm going to ask kobe to leave
so there was a that whole interaction
with the see if i have that at the
opening or no click on uh well the
challenge is it's going to take a minute
to see it anyways
i think the event holders have to be
more organized to provide a better level
of security for the talent coming in
because talent doesn't know your
audience talent wants to feel protected
it's the job of the event
hoster the host of the event to protect
the talent that's coming in so we have
people that come here all the time let
me tell you what we do did you see the
car parked outside okay what do we do
with that we want our talent to feel
safe that guy's a share of 16 years by
the way he's been you know if you see
who's what his background is somebody
tries to do something here we're
protected right guns blazing
everything's prepared right we want to
make our talent feel special that's
exactly what these guys got to do right
there 5 000 people rushed the stage
so so he's sitting right next to me and
all of a sudden boom everybody rushes
the stage
he's like what the hell is going on i
got security at the front you know the
next thing you know things change but
anyways we'll see what's going to happen
here uh thank you they had phones
yeah let's go to the next story let's go
to the next story is and by the way
we're going to get to the uh row
weight story that you know the supreme
court leaker we're going to get into
that here in a minute as well next story
i want to get into is the amber herd
with uh uh with johnny depp i'm assuming
you guys are following the story to an
extent there's only so much i can take
yeah i mean i i i get that i don't even
know why it's public quite frankly i
think that's a private matter i don't
like the fact that it's that public i
mean we have other issues that should be
public that we follow that affects us
this doesn't affect us at all don't you
appreciate that they make the amber
heard johnny depp trial public but not
the epstein trial well listen
it it it says a lot by the way it says a
lot but let me kind of give you the
story
obviously it's been going back and forth
johnny got a lot of the story from his
end that's been out and you heard the
recording you heard her reaction his
finger being cut hey he keeps calling
her misheard misheard misheard he
finally files the divorce i don't want
to do anything i'm god you know i want
to you know and then she comes out and
the story with him
her hooking up with james franco and
then her for one minute dating elon musk
and elon musk comes out and says good
things about johnny hey listen i want to
stay out of this but you know her and i
had a thing together amber heard calls
her trial the most painful and difficult
event in her life as she kicks off
testimony against johnny depp amberhead
began testifying wednesday for a lawsuit
brought by her ex-husband johnny depp
describing the trial as the worst
experience in our life this is horrible
for me to sit here for weeks and have to
relive everything
uh hear people that i knew some uh well
some not my ex-husband with whom i
shared a life with speak about our lives
in a way that they have this is the most
painful and difficult thing i've ever
done
uh
have ever gone through heard is the
second witness her legal team called to
the stand following testimony of don
hughes a clinical and forensic
psychologist
hughes who evaluated her and reviewed
therapeutic and
legal records relates to her diagnosis
and actress as post-traumatic stress
disorder caused by intimate partner
violence from dep hughes said that in
therapeutic sessions heard recounted
incidents where dep physically beat her
performed a cavity surge
and penetrated her body with a glass
bottle heart is expected to testify
about those events in the stand okay so
before you give your thoughts on you
know whatever other details you know
about it
so far
who do you believe in this story here
are you sitting there saying
you know i'm kind of believing what
johnny's saying i'm kind of believing
amber saying quite frankly i don't know
who the hell is telling the truth where
do you guys stand with this i think
they're both telling the truth okay
extremely toxic relationship they're on
the stand they're under oath they're not
allowed to lie and they get caught in a
lie that's big trouble well at least for
some people in court um
it is one of those situations where you
know the relationship obviously had so
much passion you guys have all been in
one of these uh that it just got
turned as as good as it got it it got as
bad as it got you know and uh
i kind of believe both of them um
what the results should be is you know
if either of them committed a crime and
it sounds like perhaps they both did
then maybe
there's charges that are pressed i i
don't know um
in terms of it being public well that's
uh
that's showbiz isn't it i mean it's
hurting their careers and helping their
careers at the same time do you think
this is hurting or helping their careers
individually it's helping johnny's
hurting amber's right now why do you
think it's helping his hurting her well
because he was the one that got
cancelled first before the trial came
out we just assumed that he was you know
the guy who doing all the bad stuff
turns out she was doing the bad stuff
too and now there's a big online
campaign to have her removed from
aquaman too i don't think either of them
should be removed if you don't want to
see them in a movie don't go see the
movie uh but their personal lives are
personal again these lines are blurred
it's people are so excited to get inside
the lives of these mega stars to feel
like i know them even better i know them
on a personal level i know all their bad
[ __ ] too and that's um
you know it's what it is i
i'm not a fan of that kind of interest
in people and the gossip and and all
these stories but it is fascinating
isn't it i mean it shows the mental
illness is obviously an issue here
um
fame is a huge issue here power
and uh it's all on display in court
isn't it yeah you see like right there
what you're showing right remove amber
heard from aquaman two how many people
have signed three point five million
let's look at three and a half million
like first of all like why tell me why
yeah it's a job of the director the
movie producer casting agent if they
want to have her in or not but to this
is a form of a cancer culture right to
say hey get this girl out of it you know
if you don't want to watch the movie he
made a good point don't watch the movie
johnny depp disney saying they're not
going to be doing pirates of the
caribbean caribbean i posted
a picture of the movie on facebook and i
said johnny depp is the only jack
sparrow i know as a 43 year old period i
think that thing got like 100 000 likes
and 50 i don't know how many thousands
of shares people feel the same way and
because now someone asked them a
question they said hey if
disney paid you 300 million dollars and
they gave you xyz
would you still
go back would you consider going back
and being jack sparrow in you know
pirates of the caribbean he says no i
would not i mean that's a sad situation
because how the brand managed him but
all in all in a case like this you said
johnny depp wins and amber hurt doesn't
because johnny already had tainted
reputation based on what the me too
movement kind of thing yeah adam where
are you at with this well i actually
more just want to bring this back to
matt because you've worked in hollywood
you've been in movies you've been around
celebrities this year this is this is
what you do you're an actor and there
used to be a famous line that i remember
that you would associate with hollywood
that you could say anything you want
about me as long as you do what spell my
name right
that was the whole thing with hollywood
just say whatever the hell you want just
get my name right okay well people are
certainly getting their names right yeah
and that goes back to my is this helping
or hurting their career does that still
ring true in hollywood does it is it's
is it still like say whatever you want
as long as my names are in the tabloids
as long as my name on the headlines it's
gonna be all good just spell it right
how do you process that well i mean it's
one of these things where you've got to
separate the well you don't have to it's
your decision whether you want to
separate the art from the artist
um
i think johnny depp is a terrific actor
i also happen to think he's a violent
lover okay now those i can hold
both those two truths and that's the
problem with a lot of our discourse
today is we don't it's black or white
right and usually it's all gray correct
yes and you know um michael jackson yes
r kelly exactly harvey weinstein i mean
they've been they've done all very bad
things but they've also been responsible
for very good things right it's both so
it's up to you not as not uh society in
my opinion it's up to the individual and
what we're living through right now is a
time where society
whoever the decision makers
are
dictating how people should think about
certain things i think the difference
here is guys harvey weinstein yeah that
guy's a
corrupt criminal right class a dirtbag
so you go to r kelly story is what
13 year old you know and
he's also a client many many many times
that's breaking the law right so both
broke the law you go to what was the
name next name that you said michael
jackson all right so that you know
the stories you hear from there okay
that's a completely different story but
he did make thriller
yeah he did it i i get that and by the
way like kevin spacey to me kevin spacey
is yes one of the best actors of our
generation i mean the guy how you know
kaiser say you know you can go up and
say so many different things what this
guy did there is the law
and then there is intent and then there
is personal life
you know
trevor bauer i don't know if you guys
know what trevor bowers is the pitcher
for the dodgers who's got a
he had a three-year contract for 108
million dollars i think was like uh 90
million dollars was the contract with 10
10 million dollar bonus or 18 million
dollar bonus
young award winner
young award winner which is a mickey
mouse award winner right this guy gets
suspended for two years did you see that
yeah based two years they suspended him
they're not even and
all charges were dropped against trevor
that's what's crazy about it can you
make it bigger by the way can you make
it bigger so we can read this so all
charges were dropped on trevor bauer
this is this is just talking about how
much money he's gonna lose he's gonna
lose uh 102 million dollars excuse me no
he's going to lose
roughly 47 million dollars in salary so
so
whatever the number is the guy's going
to lose a lot of money okay so he goes
in a relationship with a girl and they
say hey
i like
this style of sex
and she says
okay so you said you believe johnny depp
is a fan of rough sex so they have rough
sex the sex was so rough that she came
back for another time
okay so then second time around
they have rough sex then she goes out
there and says
well he did xyz to me then they dropped
the case then they drop all the charges
that he got and then the mlb suspends
him for two years
and you're gonna take nearly 60 million
dollars away from this guy who's a cy
young winner who is one hell of a
pitcher you're gonna do that that's
is there a law there or is that just mlb
making a decision to do that so in this
case with johnny and amber
johnny filed for divorce and johnny is
the one that's like listen
here's what happened she's dropping my
name out there and the fame and
everybody's thinking i'm a bad guy i'm
not a bad guy and then you get all these
other guys that are coming and say look
i've done cocaine i probably did you do
drugs with that person yes did you do a
drug with this person yes why'd you do
drugs with that person i'm not gonna lie
to you i just wanted him to shut up
because he was talking too much right i
don't know who he was talking about
manson or one of those guys right
but he's just
talking straight up right you're going
through this there's a part of this that
you have to be
very very careful there are people out
there relationship wise that if you're
in a bad relationship
it's realistic that you can
you can have your career being hurt if
you date the wrong person you have to be
so careful in hollywood you know who
you're married you have to be so careful
in sports who your all of this stuff you
know the movie fifty shades of grey i
don't know i know tyler's one of his
favorite books he's read them multiple
times all three always quote you always
quote things out of the book but uh i
actually read fifty shades of grey okay
when the book came out everybody in the
office was you know secretly like what
you know how that book is the kind of
book where you cover with paper like
it's like when you were in high school
yeah you have like
you got playboy right in the middle what
are you doing i'm just doing my homework
you know you got
so but everyone said what are you
reading no nothing nothing listen what
are you reading so finally like okay so
what is this all about so finally i read
the book
and there's a part of it in there where
he gets the girl to sign a contract
right i mean is it to that point
where it's like hey
trevor bauer is going to be like hey
mary i like you here's what i'd like to
do
my lawyer can you please explain to them
what's about to happen here yeah can you
imagine that setting it's like yes okay
so let me read you your rights and you
know let me read you the contract here's
what's going to happen tonight you're
going to participate in xyz are you open
to this if you get hurt and you're
barely a papa sign right here is that
what it's going to get to no 100 that's
what we're going i think 100 i think
that's a great idea a little documentary
if you're a big profile celebrity if
you're johnny depp if you're a cy young
award winner and you're making 100
million dollars if you're a famous nba
star if you're a famous hollywood guy
you have your pick of the litter
facts there's no question about it okay
so you could have amber heard you could
have this person that person okay listen
sweetheart you know we got a thing going
on before this goes any further i'm
gonna need you to sign this right if
they're willing to sign it all right you
guys can do what you guys want to do i'm
shocked they didn't have that signed
beforehand i'm shocked these guys don't
have lawyers saying johnny like you have
a hundred million dollar career at risk
and you're gonna put it because you like
to have a good time with this girl
if i'm that person's handler that
manager that uh agent
you gotta have these conversations
your whole career will go down the tubes
because you like kinky sex with amber
hurt right i had a guy by the way that
said the following i can't you know this
is a guy that's
not a well-known guy but a known guy he
said no joke he said here's all i do
he said i have my phone and i get a
video
and i produce the video with them and i
say hi
i'm john doe
what's your name such and such
we
are you agreeing to do xyz with me yes
can you please say that are you okay do
you feel safe yes can i open a door
where you can live if you want to yes
you can leave if you want to i don't
want to do you want to leave i don't
want to leave you sure yeah okay let me
just give you toward the entire place
it's just me there's nobody else here
he's kind of going like this a second
video yeah and he said yeah perfect
thank you and he files that for himself
in case this ever turns around
sense i tell you as weird as this sounds
yes i'm in the army i'm 18. okay drill
sergeant
drill sergeants and my sergeant braxton
said hey
whatever you do right before you're
about to have sex ask for the id
so the guys are like what are you
talking about he says ask for the id you
got to do it so you're serious yeah so
we go to a party all right it's getting
to that point there's three rooms that
are open hey can i see your id you want
to see my id that's stupid
yeah i know believe me i also think it's
stupid but can i see your id no i can't
get in there you're serious now you have
to realize at this point it's the most
frustrating moment for an 18 year old
boy think about being 18 years old right
at that moment but i got to see your id
shows the addition 16. okay my guy had
to run out you're like hey we got to get
out of here we're back to the base right
it's getting to that point where people
have to do such things to get protected
but question for you from a different
standpoint
in
hollywood okay
i met my wife in the industry of finance
we were both at transamerica we met
there right many people meet their
spouse you know in within the business
in the in the business do people talk to
say
hey
never date somebody like you know how
the thinkers never you know you know
date somebody's this or never do was
there anything that say never date
another actress or never date somebody
that's not in the business is there
anything like that or not at all yeah i
mean people have reputations for being
uh unstable you know and dangerous to
date sure i mean when uh me too was
first breaking out i had a lot of very
famous friends freaking out
thinking i don't know what's gonna who's
gonna come forward from the hundred
girls i was with who you know just
decides that they didn't like what i did
that night four years ago and i'm
screwed and they would have been you
know and they were sweating it
so i think the future of you know a
signed contract is not that uh uh you
know not that crazy um but videos that
people have reputations sure and uh you
know it's it's disgust but by and large
all actors are crazy so you know what
you're getting into you know that's true
they were just nutty people um myself
included you know it's just it's a weird
kind of uh profession to pursue it's
it's it's an insane profession to pursue
it's impossible the rejection is
constant so you kind of be that kind of
person who embraces rejection uh there's
got to be a lot of ego involved a lot of
ego i mean because if you're especially
if you're on camera how do i look how do
i how am i perceived how does the world
perceive me how am i viewing the world
like there's got to be a lot of that on
the other hand celebrities the celebrity
bubble the fame bubble and this goes
back to amber and johnny is the fame
bubble is so insane like look what it
did to to to i have a controversial
opinion about say bruce jenner for
example um i think a lot of his
motivations have to do with the fact
that his family became more famous than
he did right um it can drive people nuts
it is so isolating it's like it's it's
not dissimilar to uh
when you're in prison and they put you
down below what is that called solitary
solitary confinement i mean you're kind
of free to roam but you're not you're
never alone the press is always on you
the more famous you are the worse it is
and so other actors are pretty much the
only people who can understand you so
you have this dating pool of crazy uh
but it's limited to only other famous
people
otherwise there's there's a power
imbalance there that you know once you
become famous
unfortunately i don't have this problem
but once you become famous uh
you you begin to doubt anybody else's
motives for even wanting to talk to you
because people want to be around famous
people and for better or worse fame is
power today fame is a superpower
clout yeah well right cloud chasing
whatever but um yeah uh
let me ask you this so let me ask you
this so so
say uh uh say you're a tiger okay and
you're 30 years old say you're a uh
[Music]
pick an actor at their peak pick any of
these guys clooney okay so you're 35
years old take a michael jordan take a
any of these guys
should they get married or should they
just say i'm not going to get married
till my 40s what do you think is the
right move to do you're and i'm talking
about like you're the pinnacle because
johnny's pinnacle johnny's not an
a-lister johnny is a top five a-lister
actor like he ain't like a a-lister
a-lister you know he's like one some
people would consider this guy he's so
multi-dimensional how he can act the
guy's freaking ridiculous right
so if you're there what are your
thoughts you're around a lot of these
athletes you're around a lot of guys in
hollywood
do you think the right move is
to just have relationships kind of like
what leo did and just marry your career
and then later on when your number
starts with a four you can still have a
kid then get married what do you think
is the right move there well you are
married to your career i mean so that is
an inherent issue yeah any in any uh
relationship like that uh it's up to the
individual there was actually an article
it was a stupid article about george
clooney as a matter of fact and they
were comparing him to noah wiley who was
also on er at the same time and they're
like what was the difference between
noah wiley's uh lack of success and
george clooney's success and they
theorized that it was because noah wiley
got married and had kids no it was
because robert rodriguez needed somebody
to do that role and from dusk till dawn
and clooney was on hiatus that summer
and he got the part that's why clooney's
career skyrocketed it was pure chance
nothing to do with noah wiley getting
married and i'll bet you noah wiley is
just as happy as george clooney today um
clooney even said one time he you know
he finally settled down
he goes i've had all the fun any man
deserves to have i am ready to settle
down so it really depends on the
individual and a lot of times uh
people in hollywood will get in
relationships to have some kind of
stability you know as crazy as that can
be in with unstable people but the
career is so up and down so
you know a lot of people get into
relationships for that reason just have
some
something solid in their life and so i
can't say you know as a rule but it is
challenging to get married interesting
interesting i think um
throughout this conversation i'm
thinking of
basic basic premises of risk and reward
and supply and demand
so why that i mean you talked about uh
being in the financial services that's
how you met jen insurance business the
whole premise of insurance is risk
versus reward same thing with
investments uh
you bring up the trevor bauer's story
bring up the johnny depp story the amber
heard story the risk worst reward okay
you're 100 million dollar men well
what's so funny comment okay you want to
go to that all right i mean
fox hired caitlyn jenner
dog face says
now fox has two tuckers
that's a bill marjo that's expensive
um well worth interrupting me but the
risk versus reward so what's the risk
versus reward with johnny depp
well the risk is that you're putting
your whole career on the line
for this crazy girl because what's the
reward she's kind of hot and the sex is
good
probably not worth the risk trevor bauer
you're putting your whole
baseball career 100 million contract on
the line because this guard likes to get
choked a little bit probably not worth
it in these instances you probably are
going to have to
get something signed or a video like
that back to the law of supply and
demand
i mean men and women age differently
uh
i think some of these men i don't think
it's like well 40 now it's time to get
married i think it's like look
as a man it's
you you age a little more gracefully
than women typically
it takes uh to use rolo tomasi what he
says you're laughing over here women are
and men must become sometimes it takes a
few years longer for men to become great
at what they are okay women you could be
18 21 years old you're just hot as [ __ ]
boom you are hot that's it
right amber heard why is she even in the
same realm conversation as one of the
greatest actors of our generation johnny
depp because
she's hot that's it johnny had to do
movie after movie after movie and after
audition how many auditions have you
been to met
thousands thousands thousands hundreds
of thousands to be a
kind of known actor imagine that the
work these guys have had to go through
so it's a different realm between a man
and a woman so for instance when you see
my guy tyler hero 21 years old right
awesome little basketball player for the
miami heat
just won six man of the year he meets a
hot instagram girl knocks her up he's
having a baby with the girl does that
serve him well is he more focused on the
court now or is his whole career based
on a hot instagram because you got a fat
ass so it's what you're talking about
tens of thousands of years of
evolutionary biology colliding with
current society and current norms which
constantly change and are constantly
updated so these these adjustments are
going to take time we're living through
a transition period right now i think
and that's i think that's what's really
going on
anyways we'll see what's going to happen
there by the way at the end of the day
do you think do you think there's any
chance that johnny's going to play jack
sparrow again none whatsoever disney
blew that no no
300 million he said no to no johnny john
johnny doesn't need the money he doesn't
need to play that part again uh disney
screwed up wow
wow are you in the same place as well i
mean the fact that it's owned by disney
house yeah
this has been doing great lately of
course no controversy they've been
crushing it right the leadership team is
on top of it okay let's talk about
buffett a little bit let's see what
buffett's got to say charlie munger go
little business here before we get into
some of these other uh stories so
buffett got a question from one of their
shareholders okay
buffett's calls every day a coin flip
when it comes down to nuclear weapons uh
he had no answers but plenty of caution
about the threat and impact of nuclear
weapons saying that every day is a
living
with flipping a coin the world is
flipping a coin every day whether people
who can literally destroy the planet as
we know it all as we know it and we'll
do it buffett said to an audience a
berkshire hathaway shareholder saturday
unfortunately the majority prop the
major problem is that people who have
large stocks of nuclear weapons and
icbms unfortunately the major problem is
the people that own it
they talk about using tactical nuclear
weapons if someone is willing to kill
hundreds of thousands of people with
tactical nuclear weapons
why would they stop there he added it's
very very dangerous world it's a very
very dangerous well the question
submitted by the shareholder asked about
the impact of nuclear weapons on
berkshire's operations and outlook the
company maintains a number of insurance
operations and a nuclear attack would
severely impact the company's operations
as a result do you think we're
closer maybe let me ask a question this
way when's the last time we had a
nuclear wha what what was the timeline
when a truman dropped the uh uh
hiroshima yeah what's the exact date
what's the exact date i'm curious
um it's november 45 is it i'm thinking
it's um
when did strap
do you see the date here's a question
for you
are we
more likely
it's august 6th and august 9th 1914 45
which is what that's about 80 years 75
77 years right
are we closer to
that
nuclear
bomb being dropped or
is it going to happen in the next 77
years meaning do you know what i'm
asking like is it gonna be like yeah
probably the next 60 70 or someone's
going to drop a nuclear bomb
do you see that happening any time soon
here
anybody anybody no i wouldn't be
surprised if if russia used tactical
nukes what do you think is the timeline
on that on something like that because
you saw if you want to pull up putin's
article when it comes down to nuclear
what he said about the western you know
the declaring war against you know
ukraine and western uh
let me see if we have that story here
yeah there it goes it's page three and
of course we're gonna have somebody next
week peter pry that we're gonna get into
that a little bit deeper because that's
a specialty but putin says to officially
declare war on ukraine western officials
say
the declaration is expected to be uh
made on may 9th when russia marks a
victory day over the nazi germany 194
customs
and then he's talking about nuclear so
let me see go to the article about
nuclear he said something about using
nuclear if necessary they would use it
so
do you think it's that scary like do you
wake up yourself every day worried about
a nuclear war
i'll tell you i think clearly that what
we should be worried about at this point
is cyber warfare and bio warfare that's
that's what's pervasive and what's
that's going on in the atmosphere today
i mean look it's not even close russia
and us
by far and away have the most nuclear
weapons in the world it's not even close
how many thousands does the russia have
and how many thousands of us have and
then the next is like china and france
with a couple hundred it's not even
close
what was what was you you asked why are
we closer to nuclear war 77 years ago or
in 77 years from now clearly in the past
i mean all our parents for the most part
that grew up in the 50s and 60s
they used to have to do fire drills
under their desk in case there was a
nuclear war during the cold war with
russia there almost was you know correct
pigs that's why we're correct
with cuba cuban missile prices mayo all
that so
it's a lot of it is nuclear nuclear i
think i feel it's like almost like
ingrained in us like holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
but that isn't the biggest concern
at least as an american i mean
this puts another spin onto this topic
if you're in europe
you know to bring up the whole nato
topic why do you think the swedens of
the world
or the norways of the world or these
types of countries are actually thinking
holy [ __ ] like you know why is it why is
the ukraine thing happening because you
are that close to russia they are on
your doorstep
us this is one of the beautiful things
about being in the united states being
the greatest country in the world we
don't have to worry about canada
attacking us we don't have to worry
about mexico attacking us maybe a
caravan of uh migrants coming into the
country but we don't have to worry about
russia and putin on your doorstep or
even in north korea you know on your uh
southeast border getting crazy so this
is the luxury of being the united states
of america so as far as nuclear warfare
being in america being a major concern
that's not a major concern of mine so i
think there's two scenarios where we
have a nuclear bomb go off uh one is
countries countries get nukes to build a
wall of deterrence right you have a nuke
no one's going to attack you because you
have no it's not too the best no
right it's a great insurance policy um
so in one scenario some loose fish fish
fish fish style material whatever it is
gets in the hands of a terrorist and
they plant a dirty bomb somewhere that
could happen i don't i don't think
that's beyond the realm of possibility
in our lifetime
to the extent of the damage who knows um
we underestimate terrorists all the time
however um the other one is if putin
gets backed into a corner i don't i
wouldn't put it past this guy
if he thinks his life is over
or his power is done to go out with a
bang i don't think it's beyond his his
uh ability or his rationale do you agree
well to matt's point
the the
people always love to talk out of both
sides of their mouth right they say
vladimir's putin is crazy he's got
cancer he's losing his mind he's an evil
warmonger and at the same time they say
no he'll never use nuclear weapons it's
not an option won't happen impossible
and let's not forget that they have the
ability of using tactical nukes not
massive mother of all bombs 5 500 ton
you know nuclear weapons they can use
tactical nukes and i think we just we're
going to send over 33 billion dollars in
in military aid to ukraine right and you
can see what we've provided already
right we provided 5500 javelin missiles
which is one-third of our stockpile if
we continue to provide the ukrainians
with weapon system after weapon system
after weapon system and intelligence you
it's a match point you think he won't be
backed into a corner and say all right
i'm done with this no more
you've pushed me to the brink and he'll
use i i i do not think in any manner are
tactical nukes out of out of the
question on the homeland i doubt it
right like we would reign hellfire
we we would
it's mutually assured destruction but
but to use it on ukraine no i don't
think that's out of the question in any
realm at all i don't think it's out of
the question for him to launch one of us
on his way down either honestly i mean
people say oh no no he would never do
that he's not suicidal what if he's
about to die you know or if he's about
to be dethroned or about to be
assassinated
right do we have are his are the people
who work at the russian nuclear silos
loyalists or are they scared for their
life too that's what it comes down to if
i'm an intelligence officer in the
united states i am trying to infiltrate
the people who work at the damn silos
and say if vlad launches don't press the
button you know what i mean whatever you
want a billion dollars come to the state
don't press that damn button that's
that's that's how it looks to me you
know that brings up the what was the
situation with uh the general who called
china on uh yeah mark milley yeah yeah
yeah general millie right right you you
gotta he got a he got a lot of praise
but he also got a lot of heat
for undermining trump the people in the
trump campaign how dare you undermine
the president united states and call our
enemy china and assure them of to
reassure them or a big difference what's
the difference that that's a traitor
that trump wasn't trying to nuke anybody
this guy is at a place where
uh yeah millie's a traitor that there's
no depends on your perspective some
people call him a hero but i get but but
some people do but any of course of
course democrats would call him heroes
one million percent democrats would call
him heroes to do something like that and
lincoln project folks would call him
heroes but that's not a hero okay that's
not a hero it's called have a crucial
conversation with the guy and get the
right people in the room to have that
meeting with them now that's a different
story in this situation
this happened and the problem with the
following situation is is this in
america americans call him hero okay
americans are calling this melee
situation through in there as a hero
that's problematic in russia
you know what they would call somebody
that went against putin in russia we
would call that guy a hero but russians
are not going to call that i don't know
if you don't know what i'm saying to you
what i'm saying to you is their loyalty
is to their country americans loyalty is
not to their country it's more to the
political party that's the biggest [ __ ]
show we're dealing with in america
they're more committed to their
political party than that red white and
blue flag and that's a problem but going
back to a guy like this i don't know if
i disagree with uh uh matt by the way
and and a part of it is the following
here's a part of it is this a real story
uh
yeah this is a rule to undergo cancer
surgery yeah that's a real story putin
has cancer yes sir yeah is this actual
facts yeah this is the first time i'm
hearing this no no this is a fault you
know he's been sick but i don't think we
quite knew exactly yeah russian if you
want to read the article go back to the
top so i can read it so
make a little bit zoom in a little bit
more russian president vladimir putin is
about to undergo surgery cancer surgery
and temporarily hand over power to hard
line former federal police chief
according to a new report putin will
transfer control of russian government
to nicolia patruchev
head of russian federal police security
council while he is in incapacitated
during and after the procedure according
to a video from the mysterious telegram
channel generalist we are on saturday
the channel which is
perpetra uh reportedly purportedly run
by a former russian foreign intelligence
service lieutenant general known by the
pseudonym
viktor
mikholovic reported that putin has been
told by doctors that he must go in
operation now who knows what's going on
here as well you don't know what this is
big news what kind of cancer does the
article go on and say what type of i
think why are they thyroid
thyroid cancer ooh that's not good i i
think that's why he's been putting on
weight the past couple years and let me
let me do some more research into it
i'll get back to you
yeah but but the reality of it is the
following if you push the guy in a
corner
he's not a guy that's not gonna do
anything no he the only thing the only
saving grace is the following he's got
kids but he would get his kids to live
somewhere else unless there was
retaliation
and he loves his country he truly loves
russia and he knows
if he did anything to america
he's going to destroy so many of his own
people
and he has to privately by himself say
are you okay with that do we know he
loves his country though i know he said
to soldiers to be slaughtered and you
well like massive numbers does he love
us those are those are the most loyal to
this country yeah but you can say the
same thing about every you know does
truman really love his country when he
did that you've got to completely ask a
question but i don't i think so
that to me goes to he loves the ideas
of what russia meant to him way before
what it is today he loved that his
loyalty is to that like to him it was an
insult saying who were you to think
ukraine's not part of russia i'm sorry
you are russia like his ideas
is the og ideas of back in the days not
the new progressive ideas that you know
some folks think that russia have i
think that's where he's going to go and
say
you know whoever he admires like
everybody has somebody they admire
that's dead right think about who you're
going to say like who you wanted to make
proud right is his going to be a stalin
or a lenin or a father or somebody that
he worked under kgb i don't know but
he's gonna say i'm gonna meet that
person one day
is that the would my loyalty go to
something like that i don't know so my
the only saving grace i have is that
when he gets to that point he's not
going to want to do it because it's
going to backfire in ways that it's
going to get very very ugly it ain't
going to be just from america i think he
would say something like russia i love
you we all have to die together
no you think that's the angle i think
because i love you so much i must
destroy the plan i think it might have
been oliver stone who was here i saw
that so that was really interesting i'm
not sure if you've ever worked with
oliver known or been in the mood i know
a little bit about it i'm sure you do
yeah yeah uh and i remember i said who
does he want to emulate who who are his
heroes is it is it stalin is it lenin he
goes no no no no no no
he's older than that mother russia i
think he said peter the great
and this is what year were peter the
great i mean this is zaris russia in the
1600s
so when we talk about what his i do
think he loves his country i don't think
there's any doubt he loves russia
um
when but when we think of russia and the
russia that he loves it's not soviet
communist red russia of the 1930s
it's the
1630s 1730s whatever your what year was
peter the great
okay early 1700s
uh
that is the greatness that putin wants
to bring to that's the first thing i
said peter the great was six eight wow
damn back then that seriously but that
is the uh the russia that i think putin
wants to make great again and
he sees what's happening you know with
the encroachment of
yeah how evil you think he is how did
you say evil or medieval medieval i mean
i don't know i i know no i get that but
how evil you think you you think he's an
evil guy
yeah i do and i but i also think there
are uh a lot of people who we look up to
who
anyone from the other side of the the
river would say oh that's an evil you
know bastard too
i think he's evil i i can understand why
people don't but
there's a there's a quote that
when you murder people
yeah well there's a quote that um i saw
on the lex fordman podcast i don't
remember the name but the guy said
listen
some great men
are not necessarily good men uh and
there's no doubt that he is a cunning
political figure to stay at the top of
russian politics for the better half of
two decades and then some when you could
easily just have a drink of a cocktail
and end up dead
he's got to be
don't
undermine i'm not saying you but don't
undermine how savvy of a political
figure this man is uh yeah and again he
would make that mistake exactly he was
he he got brexit through and you know
from his couch so the the um
the the the cancer thing is concerning
though i i had no idea about that i
think that's a a story that we're gonna
need to keep our eyes on there's a part
of it where let's just say if you have
something where you know you're going to
die you make decisions in a different
way because urgency is at the top
so there is a part of it where if that
is the case now what that
decision-making process is going to be
nobody knows
but if a guy like that is driven by
i'm gonna get even with you or revenge
i think he's gonna spend the last uh
you know a few years or a few months or
whatever he's got doing some kind of a
retaliation is that going to be nuclear
is that going to be cyber i don't know
their ability to do cyber attack is
apparently better than anybody else in
the world so if they wanted to really
make our life a living hell
and confuse the [ __ ] out of everybody
mess with elections mess with this mess
with that they can definitely do that
but we'll see what's going to happen i
don't know if he's going to do nuclear
but
one of us is going to be right the
challenges if they do nuclear we may
never be able to tell the other guy
you're right that's the problem exactly
we may not have that as kids either
that's going to that he's gonna be or he
won't be he won't be he won't be able to
protect us
during global uh nuclear warfare i mean
right there's there's no safe island
somewhere where you're not gonna get
fall out i have i i don't know i don't
know okay next story
fun conversation yes let's talk about
this guy named joe biden okay let's talk
about what he's got going on
[Laughter]
okay so uh joe biden proposes largest
tax increase since lbj political insider
biden's 2023 fiscal budget reposes that
all the bad ideas that congress won't
pass and has a new twist the coveted
liberal wealth tax bidens wishlist costs
for increasing the top marginal tax rate
to 39.6 from 37 it would also uh nearly
double on capital gains to 39.6 for
people earning over a million dollars
this would be the highest tax rate on
investment gains since 1920s this tax
unrealized gains which are not taxed
until assets are converted to income
liquid since liquid assets make up less
than 20 the wealth investors will have
to incentivize
to hold liquid assets such as real
estate to avoid liquidating stocks to
pay taxes rather than sell stocks to
diversify to reinvest investors will be
forced to sell stocks to pay taxes on
realized capital gains do you think
there is a chance that any of this
stuff's going to pass through or do you
think a guy named joe manchin is going
to say listen have i not already made it
clear i'm not supporting a massive tax
increase what do you think is going to
happen here i think you're right i don't
think anything's going to really get
passed uh it may be a baby step maybe a
part of that uh
proposal gets gets through the you know
that everyone can agree upon is a
reasonable tax but that at least we're
talking about politics now what we
should be talking about tax rates what
is a fair tax rate what is an unfair tax
rate what is an unfair loophole for the
wealthy what is you know
a bad policy you always talk about
democrats having terrible fiscal policy
what are the good policies where do you
draw the line when you talk about taxes
being a a punishment or a reward for
being a member of a society where you
can become wealthy what is that line and
that's what the debate is and it shifts
depending on the economic state of the
country does it let me ask you so how
hard do you think it is to start a
business and make it succeed how hard do
you think it is i know how hard it is
okay how hard do you think it is it's
really hard so unpack that like how hard
is really hard like
what a lifetime of commitment
does it affect your personal life in
every way do you miss some birthdays do
you miss practices do you miss dinners
do you miss
how many people are willing to go
through that okay so now let's go
another side what else a job or
occupation is harder than being a
business owner
that requires a lot of risk
and requires
you
having to
do work that you're not going to get
paid maybe any money for a while what's
harder job than that
professional athlete
i think professional that's just random
that's it but i think that's a game
though i think that's genetics a part of
it is genetics a part of it is i can't
jump 46 inches right
so i think that is the luck of the draw
like shannon sharp says listen man i
understand i was born like this
there's nothing you can do to be as
athletic as i am right you've seen
shannon sharp yeah guy's a monster right
what do you think is as hard
as that i struggle to answer that
question because i think every endeavor
is a business in right
unless you're an artist but you're still
trying to sell your you still gotta eat
yeah but but but the risk of starting a
business putting your all your money in
it
it is so
challenging
so hollywood let's go to hollywood it is
so hard to make it in hollywood how hard
is it it's easier to get struck by
lightning twice in your life than to be
successful working okay so look what you
just said right now but i'm okay really
so yeah so let me ask let me ask you a
question you think uh steph curry you
know do we have a stephen curry without
a uh dell curry
no no we don't have a stephen curry
without delker do we have a peyton
manning or eli manning without archie
manning no sir do we have a tiger woods
without his father no do we have a the
williams sisters without the father
richard no we don't have it right okay
so that's luck of the draw right who
your father is there's a lot of incent
and benefits that you have with that
but
some of these guys that work their asses
off to get there man if a guy gets paid
a lot of money and he had to do a lot of
sacrifice and work to get there i
support that cause from to make that
money you have to create incentive for
whatever is very very hard or else
people are just not gonna do it that's
the basic premise for me with taxes
right i get that whatever's very hard i
want to create that incentive bigger for
you so now
as a government when it comes down to
taxes so you're you're a parent you have
kids
you're
a parent you have two kittens i'm a
parent i have four kids right as a
parent who has kids
you know
you
as a as a parent sit there and say that
guy took that pressure off my plate wow
pretty impressive so how can free market
individuals take pressure off
the government what can we do to take
pressure off the government to go have
to solve certain people's problems so
they don't have to do it free market
free enterprise does it how can free
enterprise
help the government's job get easier
make your life easier by charging you
less taxes
okay so let me go a little bit deeper
than that i think the way the government
we help the government is
instead of that individual that wasn't
going to have a job and you were going
to have to help him with health care you
were going to help them with
a benefit you were going to have to bail
them out i create a business i hire them
i get them a job i give them good health
insurance i give them good
travel vacation all that i give him a
good environment that he's gonna develop
and work and do good things for himself
i just took a liability
away from the government having to fix
that so essentially we're now partners
in this endeavor but you took zero risk
in that relationship i took the risk so
i helped you i
as the institution say the government
assistant says you you did that for 88
people here's an incentive thank you for
doing that you did that and created 10
thousand jobs you did i don't have to do
that [ __ ]
thank you thank you for doing this right
that's the incentive for me anybody
that's willing to do that my hat's off
to you because you made the government's
job easier but we don't explain it that
way
that's just going to say you guys don't
have a good spokesman for this no we do
not you're right and you haven't since
the 80s you're totally right i told i
sit and i listen to some of this i'm
like how can you not explain this
argument in a better way so for me
then somebody says they're like hey that
guy got this much money oh really yeah
do you have a problem with that i don't
have a problem with that guy worked why
don't you go do it if it's so easy he
busted his ass okay hey this guy
inherited this much money okay sure i
can understand that we can talk about
that but at the end of the day that that
guy's parents work to give that guy the
money what typically happens when
inheritance comes to a guy that never
earned it we know what happens we don't
we've read the stories we know the
stories i had a guy on my podcast three
years ago and he was working with the
franklin templeton family worth five
billion dollars and there were 16 kids
and he says they came to me and it's an
open story people know about it so it's
not like he told me about this on you
know on the interview because people
knew about the story
he said the the the leader at the top
who made the money the one that did the
work he gave everybody money and he gave
made everybody's life so easy so he made
my job so hard because this guy's job is
to work with the wealthy family's kids
to get them tonight he says the same
thing that you see happen to everybody
drugs alcohol all this stuff okay that's
a completely different conversation but
83 of millionaires in america are
self-made so we can't say well that's
what the rich kids no that's not true 83
percent of millionaires are self-made
and around 60 some percent of
billionaires are self-made okay that not
self-made as in didn't get any other
help to help them out it's just the
money didn't come from parents to them
so i think the tax program you have to
think for yourself
what do we want to do how do we want to
incentivize this leads to
inflation when people ask the question
they say how did inflation happen
okay
how did inflation happen yesterday
dinkin sends me a picture saying hey
should i call you nostradamus or
whatever because and shout out to dinkin
by the way he sends me this picture
and he says uh uh gas prices in nevada
okay did you see that picture or no yeah
did you see what the numbers were tyler
i'm gonna try to send this to you
uh which mac you're gonna send it to vt
macbook pro okay
so see if you have it to show this okay
tell me if it's coming to you or no
it should come right now you got it take
a look at this okay
this is gas prices in nevada zoom in a
little bit more okay this is two days
ago
8 25
for
diesel man 8 25 849 873 890 okay
so do you know when i watch this what i
say i'm it's it's okay i'm not affected
by it me
but you know when i look at this what i
say who the hell can afford to pay 8.25
hey son can you come visit me haven't
seen you for two weeks mom you're 18
miles away
it's gonna cost me 22 to come visit you
i can't do that mom what do you mean you
can't come you don't love your mom mom i
love you i just can't come pay you 22
bucks on gas to come over there right
so inflation is a by-product of what
corporate greeting money supply and
demand
um
the ebbs and flows of the economy
and
potential
economic policy
so so so go to the first one inflation
is a byproduct corp agreed unpack that
these gas companies don't have to charge
this much
okay so these but they're doing it
because they can
not now maybe there's supply chain
issues maybe that you know so then let
me ask you this question there but i
don't think so let me ask you this
question how come they didn't do this
two years ago
how come they didn't do this three years
ago if you're saying to me if that's the
argument where the argument is they did
it because they can't well two years ago
every no one was driving so they
couldn't do it then go three years ago
how come they didn't do three years ago
how come they didn't do it four years
ago how come they didn't do it five
years ago
i don't know but but meaning so then why
do they choose to do it now but that's
not the argument right then the argument
becomes
if the reason why this is it because of
corporate greed well
maybe they could have done this three
years ago but they didn't how come they
didn't do it then so maybe that's not
number one do i think it's on the list i
think for sure it's on the list yeah i'm
not i'm not sitting here yet i think
it's on the list okay so okay let's go
to another one i had andrew yang sitting
right here three weeks ago right and we
talked about ubi right universal basic
income
when he first proposed it you're like
okay elon musk is saying ai is coming
and you what you have to worry about is
ai and then that one interview with jack
ma or jackman's like i think the human
brain is more this and elon's like yeah
that's where you're wrong and we
disagree i don't know if you remember
that interview yes it was powerful
between the very awkward between the two
and elon's like what are you talking
about here right okay so he said jacob
was not picking up on elon's joke no
it's like it's relaxed it's a joke guys
yeah so no one got it so elon's saying
that so you know this guy comes out
andrew like
well we're gonna pay a thousand dollars
a month and here's this is what milton
friedman announced and i'm like milton
friedman would say something like this
dude that's crazy so let me go do some
due diligence no no milton friedman
never said just give up money milton
friedman had a negative
income tax which means if you're making
you know if the
whatever income is 40 grand the average
income is 40 grand if you bust your tail
and you make 30
we'll work to help you out because you
earned it will give you a little bit
less of a tax a little bit bigger of a
tax cut so you have to do it i think the
reality is the best thing they can do
with taxes anybody making less than 40
grand just don't tax people less than 40
grand just keep a little bit easier for
them to to get rid of that any
republican comes forward with that
platform yeah it's they're they're you
can't beat them why don't the democrats
do that but okay i agree with you so but
the part with inflation now ubi ubi
didn't work
we just tested it it didn't work we
couldn't mean the ppp program the ppp
program that was a big big leaky bucket
i mean to who
corporate yeah of course
so like i mean broadstairs there's all
these these there's all these
money there's all these tranches of
money they got they got injected into
the economy stock market got a couple of
hits yeah the corporations all got their
ppp and then the people got there
extended state unemployment right so
which of those three is really the the
poorest policy was it the the extended
unemployment you could argue that it was
because a lot of people were motivated
not to work i know several who were
making more on the unemployment during
covet than they were ever making at
their jobs so that's an argument i could
i could you know engage with um
but i don't think it was just giving out
a couple checks of 2500 bucks most of
that money went to food and gas
right i don't think people hoarded it
and are are sitting on it today causing
this inflation but i don't think they
did that i think they i think that money
went back to large corporations sure
because because what what people don't
realize is the spending habits didn't
change
i can give money to a person like you
know how uh every time i got somebody
that's on the corner that's asking me
begging me for money you know what i
always do i said here let's go to a
restaurant you're hungry yeah yeah yeah
no no i'm good man oh okay i gotta move
yeah yeah sorry let's go to the
restaurant i got you what would you and
i and by the way some of them that say
yes i was with tikkun you remember when
we did this in dallas
i brought a homeless guy in my car i
take them i said whatever you want get
out so who else is up there get them
stuff the double disc dogs get all of
them we brought them i get everybody
food cool no problem but what happens if
you give drug addict money right what
does he do
more what happens if you buy an
alcoholic money i'll you know he goes
and buys more alcohol right what
happened if you buy somebody who has no
understanding of finances you give him
money what does he do what does she do
they spend it the money rolls up to the
company that has the product that you're
spending money with right yeah so we
realize a ubi format does not work and
it's not the long term solution until
hardcore ai comes in which that's not
the case
how do i know that report just comes out
from bloomberg okay
and this is what bloomberg tells us
about what just happened with the number
of jobs okay page three so bloomberg
says uh u.s job openings rose
unexpectedly job openings folks can you
pull up this article so people can see
it to record eleven and a half million
people eleven and a half million jobs
let me read this one more time u.s job
openings rose unexpectedly to a record
11.5 million jobs there's 11 and a half
million jobs in america right now u.s
employers saw record levels of job
openings and workers quitting in march
pointing to intensifying labor market
tightness that will keep pushing wages
higher at a rapid clip the number of
available positions increased to 11.5
million in a month from 11.3 million in
february uh meantime a series of high
four and a half million americans quit
their jobs in march they were 1.9 jobs
for every unemployed
worker in march up from february is
there data uh describing which kinds of
jobs became available like is it hot
girl summer now the kids are just
quitting their side hustle at mcdonald's
or or is it is is it people of all ages
leaving the world but here's that's an
important decision but but i will tell
you this uh matt when i was uh
uh uh
work when i when my first business
didn't happen and i went into that forty
nine thousand dollars you know what i
was looking for any freaking job so i
used to be the top salesperson at
bally's valley's hired me back but you
know what position they gave me you know
what position they gave me no
4am oh gym i opened up the gym from 4 am
to 12. can you tell me how many times
you've bought a gym membership from 4
a.m to 12 o'clock oh you're a sales rep
i was a sales rep from 4 a.m to 12. now
i used to sell gym memberships how many
people come to the gym from 4 to 12 to
buy a gym membership lunch break or
after work that's what it is nobody buys
it so it was a way of robbie to say
here's what we're doing to you and i
laughed at him i'm like i know what
you're doing but [ __ ] i'll take that
little six dollar an hour job that
you're giving me right what's the point
i just needed a job i just need to make
some money right so for me as much as
people complain about hey there's no
jobs out there's plenty of jobs out
there if there's 11.9 million jobs if
you're really qualified and you bring a
lot of value to the table the job's out
there so going back to inflation a
byproduct of
we know putting money into the market
2.1 trillion dollar stimulus okay really
only 300 billion went to people 2.1 true
what happened to the 1.8 billion what'd
you guys do with that oh okay got it so
you're doing more this bailout type of
stuff okay so you're doing better for
the bigger companies who are lobbyists
who are helping you with your
campaigns and all this stuff so those
are the guys you're taking care of make
sense that's not capitalism folks that's
monopoly okay there's no such thing
there that calls for capitalism if a
company screws up and they're too big to
fail companies are about to go out of
business you know what happens you let
somebody else buy them that's better at
operating their own finances just like
you let chase buy women because women
screwed up that's what should have
happened with a lot of these too big to
fail companies because they're not going
to fail you know when they say too big
to fail what do you mean too big to fail
or we can't let them fail okay but what
were they worth at their peak 100
billion dollars we can't let these guys
fail so what are you saying though are
you saying today if somebody were to buy
them they're worth 10 billion but
they're not worth 10 billion they used
to be worth 100 billion i don't care
what is it worth today well today they'd
be eight billion dollars well let
somebody buy my billion dollars it's
their screw up
that's the mistake they made right but
too big to fail
is a bailout due to lobbyists coming in
and saying if you do this for me i do
this for paul manafort you're not
calling him out on the library they'll
spell his cologne yeah
i said this lobbyist i said it's the
biggest spinners in america so what do
you want to do
you know teachers union these guys all
these guys all these guys have some kind
of so so inflation you sit there and you
look at it like all these policies that
you thought were gonna favor people
and we're gonna help the people you're
really helping out those are the people
you actually hurt that's the problem
with bad policy and again this is not
described in any way from either side of
the political fence i'm kind of of the
opinion that uh it's two wings of the
same bird lately and you know the
arguments you're making
sound actually very liberal you know
but i know that's not where you stand on
the political fence especially
financially but neither party is is
engaging in this manner this level of
truth like
these policies help us
hurt you
sorry you know and both sides don't have
a solution that that fixes that that
i've seen yeah i i think i think the my
my policies are simple incentivize the
person that takes the biggest risk to
start a business the small business
owner take care of that guy because that
guy's not taking the money and you know
he's taking the money and reinvesting to
the company number two the guys that are
coming up to start their own careers
let them keep as much of the money as
they can forget about minimum wage get
rid of minimum wage but get rid of taxes
for anybody making less than 40 grand a
year
you if if right now they announced which
one you have a choice to we eliminate
minimum wage
or anybody making less than fifty
thousand dollars you pay zero in taxes
what do you think people choose
i think that's 150 i think so too yeah
so then then the argument isn't minimum
wage right right but here's the kicker
though you'd be amazed how many people
would actually say no we got to keep
minimum wage because companies were
bullied no go increase your market value
make 50k it's as if you're making 100k
because you ain't paying any taxes so
you get to keep 100 of it right so the
onus is also on the individual to go get
one of these 11.9 million jobs okay and
the company says [ __ ] this is great this
is i'll do this no problem right
then on the other side with the policies
that they're coming out with dude stop
it you're playing games with people like
all these things that you're spinning
everything you know the numbers came out
i'll read this on out the uh uh adam
alternative question for you yeah go for
it before i get into you know so i want
to talk about the the interest rates
what happened to it but yeah maybe
before we get into that let me just ask
you this question because
um the conversation we had yesterday
with tyler we were talking about uh the
bronx tale and the famous line with chaz
paul monterrey he says
c says you know the working man's a
sucker
the working man's a sucker you know and
mickey mantle ain't pain putting food on
your uh on your table
no robert de niro says no the the hero
is the working man the hero is the guy
that the working man's the guy that gets
up and does the tough labor and does the
tough job and shows up to work and eats
[ __ ] and puts foot on it that's the real
hero so you as being a former worker
bally's 4am shift that's the working man
to being a business owner
explain that maybe unpack that from your
perspective as a business owner
you could be both meaning like
matt said they don't do a good job
basically explaining all the risk that
the business owner has to basically take
on to be that person right sitting on
them job creators yeah little yeah like
billionaires and the millionaire class
are villainized in this country because
they're so wealthy
but the way that you put it is like yeah
well you want to go create 10 000 jobs
have at it that's less work that you
have to do this reminds me of the video
of that i don't want to a trans looking
guy who was like i don't have a job how
does it feel that you guys are the ones
that are that are paying my bills i
don't have to work ah you guys are the
suckers so
overall this is just an overarching
question of of
the working man the unemployed man the
the leech the welfare queen the the the
the incentivizing the job creators i
think that
that some one of the things that i've
learned just sitting next to you being
the job creator being the entrepreneur
is yes we do need to incentivize the
people who are creating the jobs yes the
working man is the hero but the only way
that they are able to be the hero is
because the job creator created the job
here's the thing like let me ask you a
question what what do i do without the
the tyler
he's choosing to do this job he does a
good job right so tyler gets it tighter
did you get a raise like
yes sir yeah thank you very much
by the way by the way 50 000 tax
brackets by the way he earned it yeah
it's not like i did him a favor he
earned it right he worked his ass off
and he brought okay great so we're
having a working match yeah so so
somebody comes in and says okay you know
we had this meeting last two days what
did you say the best we've ever had
we've never been the team's never been
this good yeah your words right correct
correct yes sir so what happened it's
the attitudes on how we're working
together right
there's no way you can build a big
company and abuse employees it doesn't
work
eventually something's happen
eventually someone's gonna say hey what
the hell are you doing and either
somebody goes elsewhere or you fire them
or they form a union like in the case of
amazon or they form a union like the
case of amazon it was alabama or i don't
know what's where they started off with
and going through that but but you're
right but to go to go to that we have to
question every policy
and ask who is this really hurting
that's what we have to ask who's this
really hurting we have to mix it up a
little bit man the angle we're taking
right now is not the best angle we're
taking we're sitting we're thinking like
the other day so give you a crazy story
i shared with this with you yesterday
i come home tico and senna get into a
big fight okay and tico's 10 years old
she's five years old and he gave her one
okay pretty solid
so
he doesn't want to sit down talk me he's
upstairs
so finally he comes downstairs he knows
he has a conversation with me
i said so what happened
he said well some people are just
sometimes annoying and you know this is
what happened i just i said so let me
ask you
you don't think you're annoying to
others you don't think i'm annoying to
you
you don't think mom's annoying sometimes
you don't think nannies you don't think
papa we're all annoying sometimes so
what do we do every time somebody's
annoying
uh he says but you're not annoying to me
i said i'm not saying no you're not
annoyed so how about mommy no mommy's
not in a fight he said somebody was
annoying i'm like okay fine so he's not
like bsn so i said okay so let me ask
you one day you're married you got kids
your 10 year old son does the same thing
you did to senna what would you do to
your son he thinks for like 15 minutes
like he's thinking he's a thinker guy
and he comes like he says i don't know
what i would do i said okay do you think
he deserves punishment yes
i said what kind of punishment he
deserves
he thinks for five minutes he's a very
smart guy says i don't know i said well
listen i'm gonna give you the
opportunity to choose your punishment
because for me
mine may be worse than yours so how
about you choose your own punishment so
he's like this is tricky here so then he
says
i think uh one year of not picking
movies and three months of no ipad he
went to like here like he didn't play
wrong he gave him him i wasn't going to
go here he did something wrong so then
i'm like i'm like okay sounds good then
he's negotiating yeah so then he says
you know what i'm just going to go to
sleep okay go
he says
okay
no i don't want to go i said dude what
do you want to do he said what's my
punishment i said let me think about he
says no i want to know tonight
i said okay
so i think for five minutes and i said
if i punish this guy
i'm just showing him that there is no
such thing as forgiveness
so then that means
he's not learning to forgive his sister
and his brother so what am i really
teaching this guy
okay i'm gonna change it up tonight so i
said tico my dad's sitting there dylan
senator dylan's like what's going to be
his punishment right
so it's a tico i'm going to confuse you
today with punishment he says what's
that
i said um
i'm not punishing you for anything you
can watch ipad you can watch your tv and
all that stuff he says wait what said
yeah he says why are you doing this i
said because i'm hoping
that you take this as a value to
strengthen our relationship
to know how much i love you and i want
to establish trust with you
and i want you to also forgive your
siblings when they screw up
is that a deal he said yes i said let's
shake on it shakes on so you're gonna
you committed to this i'm committed to
this it's a game so i come home
yesterday
it's late i'm have to shoot that video
in my office they show up i'm like dylan
how was tico today
great to go how are you today great
daddy awesome
i don't know if it's going to work or
not and if they're going to get to
punching you know fight a week or two
probably going to do it anyways right
but i think the approach we take to
punish every rich or every this or every
debt i think we have to change our
approach
because we're not understanding that
person's story
you know first time jennifer had a baby
boutique i sat there i'm like what was
this all i could never do this salute to
mothers out there right because now i
see the pain of what mothers see their
kid in a different way than a father
does right it's a different kind of an
experience
i think to sit there and just judge
everybody and say well these guys are
rich and that guys are doing this guys
and that guy's lazy and this guy
i think it's caused us to have a lot of
big problems and we need to reshift how
we view these guys we have to
recalibrate who the real hero is so the
kids know who to look up to when they
grow up
and then from there let the market
decide what they're going to be doing
but i don't think the approach we're
taking right now is working gas prices
right now 840 in nevada that thing's
going to go to 10 bucks it's going to go
to 15 bucks it's just going to hurt the
low middle income the interest rates
they're spiking it up to whatever they
raise at a half a point this week who do
you think that's going to hurt
you know
who do you think that's going to be with
a 401k in a mortgage everybody with a
401k and a mortgage mortgage
where is that story by the way but by
the rates
okay fed raises rates by half a
percentage point the biggest hike in two
decades to fight inflation so cnbc story
page three
okay
so the federal reserve one where they
raised it's a benchmark interest rate a
half a percentage point the most
aggressive step yet to fight against 40
or high inflation inflation is much too
high and we understand the hardship is
it it is causing we're moving
expeditiously to bring it back down the
federal chairman powell said the
american people he noted the burden of
inflation on lower income people saying
we're strongly committed to restoring
price stability okay by increasing by 50
basis power along with the move to
higher end rates the central bank
indicated will begin reducing asset
holding on his 9 trillion dollar balance
sheet the fed has been buying
bonds to keep interest rates low and
money flowing okay so what does this
mean here's what it means
what happens rates go up to five percent
can you go to a mortgage calculator just
go mortgage calculator okay whatever you
got somewhere there
uh all right so
when a person buys a house they buy a
house based on what loan amount interest
rate or payment on a monthly basis
people buy a house on payment right they
say i can't afford three grand a month
that's how the decisions made okay
all right so at go to six go to seven
hundred thousand dollars no go to 700
yeah keep going up keep going up make
the payment three thousand dollars okay
at three percent and my budget is three
grand a month i can get a seven hundred
and twenty seven thousand dollar loan
okay because my payment is three grand a
month
interest rates next year gonna go six
plus so go to six percent just change
that that's all you need to change put
six there right boom
now it went to four thousand thirty six
but let's bring it back to three
thousand dollars
so three thousand dollars the only loan
i can now afford is what
539 it dropped 200 000
so somebody may say well pat what does
this really mean it means two things
home prices are about to drop
10 to 30 percent
okay
and people buying homes mortgage and
real estate industry is going to get hit
very very hard okay it's natural this is
going to happen
and
folks are going to sit there saying what
the hell do i do because i can still
only afford what 3 000 a month
rent control ain't going to change
rent's going to go stay the same if not
even go higher because when [ __ ] like
this hits the fan guess what uh renters
do they say well listen you can't afford
buy buy a house anyways so you gotta pay
ten percent more rent right so rather
than your rent being three thousand
dollars a month is thirty three hundred
dollars a month
inflation comes back and hurts the
people that we wanted to protect
initially
so we make a decision that sounds good
and we're heroes today but we hurt them
two three four five years down the line
and we're feeling it today and by the
way as ugly as it is today this is going
to get very ugly in 2023 and 2024. it's
going to get hit very very
very
hard it's coming 128 months of economic
expansion so what are your thoughts on
this
well i mean i'm no financial expert you
know as soon as
my whole life i've never i've kind of
been allergic to money and i don't know
if i inherit that from my father he was
a lawyer but never build his clients you
know we grew up pretty poor and
everyone's like you're rich your dad's a
lawyer it's like yeah why do people keep
saying that you know i mean come to find
out he just was an altruist and you know
was terrible with money didn't build his
client
um
so you know but as somebody who now has
to make money and has to pay a mortgage
i've seen these ebbs and tides you know
fluctuate all the time it it's it's
harder some years it's easier other
years i think it's got to balance out um
actually interestingly enough and not
just because i was playing him in parity
at the time
when romney was against obama and the
the financial uh situation i just
watched the big short again on the plane
ride down sick
yeah adam mckay
same movie
second to none um
i was thinking you know romney was
probably going to be the better choice
because then the banks are kind of going
to chill out and loosen up and the money
can start coming in
simply because
a lot of this a lot i think a lot of the
financial
fluctuations have to do with
who's in office who's who's who's
looking out for who again the lobbyists
and you know who's who's helping each
other at the highest level now
i've also been warned that the fed's
going to raise interest rates for a long
time it's been a long time since they
had i don't see this as something that's
insane if it goes up and up and up and
up yeah we're going to have a bigger
problem but i don't think it's going to
really
i don't know what difference it's going
to make at this point you know what i
mean in a negative way
it's got to get better inflation has to
come down
oh no no
don't get it twisted you don't think
that the interest rate hike will bring
inflation down no it it will i think it
will here's why i say i think
because
i also thought
that uh uncertainty would have taken
gold to 5000 and gold never moved
okay so there's a lot of triggers that
historically
if i press this
this goes up right if i press this this
closes a lot of those things that
historically have worked together it was
completely out the question during covet
like wait a minute what gold is supposed
to go up gold state flat bitcoin went
here you know rates like hey so i don't
know what's going to happen but i will
tell you he has to do it he can't keep
the race that i don't even know why
they've kept the race that down for that
long that's the question right i don't
know if they've kept that down for that
long
but at the end of the day the only
reason he has to do it is because
there's inflation the only reason we
have inflation is because we print way
too much money the only reason we print
away too much money is because we listen
to everybody complaining way too much
the only reason we listen to people
complain too much is because we try to
please the people to win votes and win
elections and then boom this is a ripple
effect so everything is a ripple effect
and back again and back again so
uh unfortunately that's the way we have
our election process our election
process is by people getting up there
and putting the fear in voters to win
their votes whoever is able to persuade
the best and you can even use the word
manipulate to get people to realize and
create a massive enemy hey then we're
gonna go to xyz for you but then the
same people that voted for that policy
end up getting shafted that's just how
this thing works and we have to get a
little bit more deeper
to
you know like hey you know
i want to buy some roblox dad okay you
want to buy roadblocks yeah go bring
your money i'm paying for it yeah okay
i'll buy all of it
all right spend all the money on roblox
all right that i want to buy this go use
your money i ran out of money okay i
don't have it
right but dad i didn't tell you about
roblox you chose to roblox you were
happy for two weeks when you bought all
the roblox how come you're not happy now
there is consequences man and we're not
talking about consequences fortunately
financial literacy is now becoming more
and more required in certain school
systems my daughter's goes we go
very nice public school system by design
and i'm going to take it with her this
summer she's got to take a financial
literacy awesome so i'm going to take it
with her sick yeah just to get into i
love that um but you're right i mean you
know a lot of it is cultural we the this
generation you know they call it the
helicopter parenting or
you know uh i like to say when
everyone's special no one will be you
know the participation trophy generation
and it it it you hit on a point there
with uh talking about your kids asking
for stuff we gotta
learn as a people
that because we're in a capitalist
system
whatever the whatever the policies are
going to be
it starts at home
financial responsibility starts at home
and
i think there's a lot out there where it
it
finances are
are the the product of something
beyond me right
and that's got to probably change
as a cultural as a culture where yeah
with the saddle yeah you know i'm
processing all this i'm listening yeah
you're the money guy i mean i i think
well ultimately it comes down to doing
the hard things and having the tough
conversations and looking deeper down
the surface like we
like
these types of things are
essential to understand if you're going
to be
living in a capitalist society living in
america
but back to our initial point
it's much easier just to watch the amber
her johnny depp story and just kind of
yeah what's going on with that well sure
in your spare time but work is different
now than it ever was yeah but you know
work is not it's not what you're gonna
say no it used to be you go to work you
get a salary you know your salary was
you know what your annual budget was all
that stuff that's off the table for the
most part today it's entrepreneurship is
more and more important the the whole
nature of a side hustle as a positive is
weird to me you know what i mean that
you need two jobs you want a second job
if you're trying to get ahead
financially because your first job
doesn't pay you enough now it's almost
essential that both couples work you
know both members of the both parents
have to work one probably has two jobs
that's weird that's so what's that
what's that from those so then so years
and years and years of
maybe financial
disparity between the what the rich and
the poor i don't know can you can you
pull up uh [ __ ] like uh
uh uh uh cost of college tuition
over the years right now is looking at
colleges because because when we when we
look at the cost of college tuition i'll
just trigger matter right now
matt's getting triggered but but think
about it think about that because when
you look at the cost of college tuition
um
can you go to twitter the one i posted
where
uh i showed the numbers of what's
happened to cost of college tuition if
you go a little lower you'll say that's
just i put up a bar but here's here's
what happens with
how cost of living has increased when it
comes down to college debt they're
talking about writing off the debt right
it's like hey you know just forgive
everybody when it comes down to college
debt okay
in the college debt situation what what
individuals are involved let's go
through it number one is the institution
which is what the actual
college right
two is the student who's involved in
that relationship three
is the parent
who's involved in that relationship
uh four is the government that's
involved in that relationship and then
let's put lender there it could be the
same but it's involved in a relationship
right so we have what we have the
institution at the top we have the
student the parent
the government and the lender right if i
said it correctly right those five
people that are involved okay
so
college
used to be very cheap wasn't that
expensive right if you look at that
right there
that's the college tuition inflation
since 1980 according to cpi actual
inflation
college tuition is up
1184 inflation is only up 228. who the
hell let these guys do this
now if you look at this 220 versus 1184
go go a little bit lower on the tweet by
the way go a little bit lower on the
tweet just get back and go to the
following stuff that i say below yeah so
uh average salary in 1980 was 21 200.
average salary in 2021 is 51 480.
it's up only 142
yet college tuition is up
1184
how am i supposed to keep up as a parent
right so so when did this change here's
how it changed you ready folks here's
how it changed
the moment
the government said we'll help colleges
out with your student loans it became a
business colleges and the government
teamed up together then colleges had
no limitations on what they could charge
they said we're going to charge this
much no problem we'll lend it out we're
going to charge you no problem we'll let
them out and the government said hey you
can't write off your student loan you
have to pay for it but i can write off
all the other debt yeah so you enslave
so you were against slavery now you just
turned me into a slave what happened
there why are you doing that to me i
can't pay these payments
oh but it's for the good of your future
because a degree is going to change your
life oh really most people who get a
degree don't even work a job that has to
do anything with that degree what the
hell do you mean it's for the better me
for me to get so they created a monopoly
for colleges colleges took advantage of
that because colleges are the ultimate
capitalist by the way no write-off tax
advantages they have the biggest
loophole in america harvard's sitting on
40 billion dollars
of cash endowment they can literally for
the next 100 years not take a penny from
their students and they will still have
money 100 years from now with the amount
of money that they got in the bank but
what do we do who paid the price you
know who paid the price
you know who paid the price
not the institution they won not the
lender they won not the government they
got re-elected you know paid the price
the parent and the student that's right
and over and over and so when they're
like we should forgive the debt why
forgive the debt why put the write off
on everybody else we should we should
forgive it no no
before we forgive it i'm open to
forgiveness
but step number one
let's go get colleges to kind of catch
back up to cpi 228 which means to be at
228 you know what the average college
you know annual like you know what's the
annual tuition for harvard right now 55
grand 56 grand more than that harvard
would need to come down to 11 000
and then let's forgive it do you know
what i'm saying so why don't we bring it
back down to harvard's what it's it's
academics fifty-one thousand dollars
without financial aid forty-nine
thousand dollars a year earlier one room
and board and other fees brings it up to
seventy four thousand dollars and during
covet they asked hey since you're doing
everything on zoom for the degree can
you lower the price what did harvard say
nope same exact price
now you're telling me that capitalists
are greedy i don't see anybody more
greedy than these college institutions i
think you're absolutely right
i got a full tuition scholarship to the
boston conservatory
and i had to come come up my own room
and board i worked studied my
grandfather helped me out a couple
hundred bucks here and there
um
but that was my option it was either
scholarship or no college
i just paid off my 40 000 in student
debt a year ago no [ __ ] that was the
last thing i had i paid off my timeshare
in like three years i paid off all the
other things but i just kept that
college degree what year did you
graduate 95.
so that's almost twenty seven years
twenty seven years
a month going to sallie mae
well on average it takes 18 to 20 years
to pay off student debt that's the hour
i deferred from time to time okay well
there you're starting out yeah that
brought it way up but yeah i mean it's
insane it talk it is just one of these
bills and it is the entree into the
middle class that said however i think
we're going to see a massive backlash i
think well first of all a lot a lot of
kids are going to look at the situation
today there are kids with i know a kid
in my town has got a 4.68 gpa couldn't
get in any of the schools she applied to
it's insane how's that possible well
there's a whole like northeast bias now
um there's colleges are it's it's a big
story new york times ran a big thing
about it um now it sounds like wow you
couldn't get into your school you got to
go to a lesser school and to an extent
they're right and you could argue
arguments have been made
going into a lesser school is better for
you like if you go to harvard as a
doctor you're in there with the best
damn doctor so you come out as like
fourth best doctor you're you're not
happy you go to ithaca college you know
you're the best doctor there you have a
great life great career because you were
the best doctor in your office
yeah yeah so i think we're going to see
a lot of that i think college is the
backlash is going to be real we're
letting a lot more international
students too that's a big part of it um
but also you have now this whole
generation being raised on instagram
learning you can become a millionaire
without having to go to college correct
you know there's all these hacks these
these financial hacks these career hacks
so is it more on the student or is it
more on the parent because when i was 17
18 years old applying for college dude i
couldn't
tell you what the hell i wanted to do
with my life i couldn't tell you why i
wanted to go to college it's just that i
just knew that it was almost robotically
the correct thing to do was to go to
college and it is to get a middle-class
job but today you can go to a state
school for almost free or free a lot of
states now have programs where if you go
to school and it's in community college
state college it is free there are state
programs that will the loan forgiveness
is already happening at the state level
so ultimately what we're not talking
about is the concept of college or the
concept of a higher education i think
that's invaluable i think that's
important not necessarily for your for
your iq but certainly for your eq i
think i learned more about
um networking and who to hang out with
and who's got their thing going on and
who to hang out with and who to maybe
invite to the parties and like i think i
learned more of that in college than i
did in a certain class or two but
ultimately what we're talking about is
roi return on your investment of the
amount of debt or the amount of uh cost
that you're paying for college if you
can get it for free i think it's a
no-brainer would you disagree
yeah if you can get whatever if you get
college for free nothing is free no no
no no no no no no i'm sorry i'm not
saying that's free tuition like how if
you pays for it if you get uh free tour
we go to the state school community
because you're paying the teachers
state taxes yeah yeah exactly so it's
not free
just to clarify what adam said really
quick is the taxpayer should pay for you
to go to school
not to improve your intelligence or
learn anything new but so you can party
and learn how to network and get a
little check off that says you went to
college it just well if you're holding
the colleges accountable for providing
the education that you're supposed to
provide then you know you could argue
that it's for the betterment of society
in general but that gets to you know the
evil word socialism which we can't utter
you know what i mean but again the
colleges aren't teaching the kids what
they're supposed to do that's learning
right yeah you've seen the stats where
it's the the education level is easier
and easier and easier to pass schools
now right at every at almost every grade
they're catering to the students not the
not the needs like i i think there's
everything wrong not everything but so
much wrong with the idea that you have
to go to college to to make yourself in
life it's like no dude go learn a trade
well there's learned that that's
like you say there's hacks you can start
your own business hell look how many
people are millionaires on only fans
like they're entrepreneurs i don't agree
with genetics
everybody has to go to college to make
it in life it's absurd and to matt's
point you are seeing a huge backlash to
this i mean people are realizing that
college is a scam i mean it's just not
worth it seventy percent is a waste of
time thirty percent stem or if you got a
sports scholarship go forward but
seventy percent of it is a is a waste of
time
uh to go to college you know if you and
a few the schools right now it's crazy
you know in our community a lot of these
guys are guys that have money and a lot
of them are banking on vanderbilt over
any of the
you know
ivy leagues it's like vanderbilt is
where they're looking i'm like
vanderbilt interesting
so penn comes up vanderbilt comes up
duke comes up some of these guys come up
uh
but some of these guys that are ivy
league in the direction they're going
yeah i think
i think this whole system is broken when
it comes down to college and if we want
to write off the college debt i'm fully
for it but let's first lower the tuition
by 80 percent then let's write that and
by the way i'll pay for increase my
taxes a little bit but first let's
change that from 51 dollars to harvard
at eleven thousand dollars right let
them also pay a little bit of the price
because they're breaking the backs of
parents that are busting their ass two
three four jobs to be able to say i sent
my son to a good school and i paid for
it no bro it shouldn't be that much
money that should be eleven thousand
dollars great time so next story let's
talk about this uh
roe v wade which is
it's uh
you can't turn on the news without
seeing this by the way it's pretty ugly
and something that's been going on for a
while it was a concern
when uh uh
supreme court justices were chosen they
kind of knew this day was coming it's
officially here so roe v wade opera
mcconnell calls for prosecution for of
supreme court leaker
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
called for the department of justice to
investigate and pursue criminal charges
against those responsible for leaking
draft supreme court decision that would
overturn roe v wade mcconnell uh went on
uh to rip his democratic opponents for
politicizing the court and repeatedly
using leaks in an attempt to force
changes mcconnell's comments after
political publisher leaking leaked the
draft copy of justin samuel alito's
decision in an upcoming ruling on a
mississippi abortion law the ruling if
adopted by four other justices would
overturn roe v roey roe v wade which
legalized abortion nationwide in 1973
supreme court chief justice directs
marshall to investigate leak
calls that egregious breach of trust
anyways this thing's going all over the
place so what are your thoughts about
what's going on here with the story
well i think it's a travesty i think uh
roe v wade was established law for 50
years in my opinion and maybe you know
on paper i know it was never codified as
you know federal law
um
i don't think for a second that this the
problem here is the leaker it's very
telling that you know mcconnell's going
after the leaker rather than
perhaps having a conversation about the
three justices who said on their in
their hearing that they would not
overturn this ruling
those are three acts of perjury you know
you could go after just as much as this
leaker
um
i am for a woman's right to choose uh
because i am not a woman so i cannot
possibly fathom what it's like and i
know there are arguments to be made that
you know that does that shouldn't
you know be a part of the conversation
um
but it's it is it who benefits who
benefits from this
you have a base of republicans and uh
their voter base who are christian and
that's a very firm belief my brother's
very anti um
abortion he's a staunch staunch catholic
was a republican lawmaker for a long
time but also a never trumper so there's
all kinds of shades there um
but
it strikes me that this is a cudgel that
is uh an overwhelming distraction i
don't think it's going to make it all
the way it is distracting us from bigger
issues which we which we seem to be
ignoring at our peril like climate
change in my opinion
and uh once again it is just uh
i don't know it's it's such it's so hard
to talk about because it's it's go ahead
adam
no
it's there's clearly no correct answer
in in
there's if you don't want an abortion no
what was interesting we talked about
this when we were in the old office and
and you said well when when should you
have an abortion i said yeah well you
know
uh you know you should have up to x
amount of months is what i said oh
really do you think that long five
months whatever it was i said let me
actually go around the
office
and i asked everyone every woman in the
office and then i started asking men
okay when should an abortion be okay
you know
six weeks so 12 weeks 15 weeks they get
all these different answers
and i remember just getting different
answers from everybody i think we can
all be in agreement that there's the
first second third trimester you should
not be able to have an abortion during
the third trimester
that's essentially what everyone was
comfortable saying sure
during the first trimester people felt
very comfortable saying well in the
first 10 weeks 12 weeks yes that seems
very reasonable the gray area is
basically that
that
20 week mark
right where the baby is four to five
months old
is it a life is it not a life
uh that's
that's the deeper question but even even
in there are cases in third trimester
where an abortion is a medical necessity
or you have to choose between the life
of the baby and the life of the mother
imagine come having to make that
decision i mean there's this post going
around instagram right now that's really
cool i'm not pro-murdering babies i'm
pro-becky who found out at her 20-week
anatomy scan that the infant she had
been so excited to bring into this world
had developed without life-sustaining
organs i'm pro-susan who was sexually
assaulted on her way home from work only
to come to the horrific realization that
her assailant planted his seed in her
when she got a positive pregnancy test
result a month later i'm pro-teresa who
hemorrhaged due to a placental abruption
causing her parents spouse and children
to have to make the impossible decision
of whether to save her or her unborn
child i'm pro-kathy it goes on and on
and on in all these cases where this
this ruling
is is barbaric the the thing that
i as three men talking about when i know
whether women should have an abortion i
think is
is uh is almost ironic however
i also think it's a very ironic that you
know what percentage of congress people
are men 95 percent and they're the ones
making these decisions of what a woman
should do with her body and they'll have
rich by the way if they if they're their
daughters but the whole thing they'll
have access look
you know shocker alert we're not going
to solve this issue on this podcast
today but
you know you're on one camp during covet
i don't tell me what to do with my body
i put whatever i want with my body don't
tell me what to do it's like well that's
sort of the abortion
uh the pro-choice mentality is don't
tell me what to do with my body well
you're murdering someone it's not it's
just it's such a hard thing to answer
that it's a constant conversation it's
to constantly be
with the basically the way the courts
are are situated right now with the
conservative justices it's going to be a
situation this brings us back to the
conversation we were having for weeks
and weeks and weeks is
is biden going gonna pack the court you
never hear anything about that anymore
but the the this is this is gonna be a
constant cause it's a minority rule is
what it is 68 of the country is in favor
of
for access to abortion care it's like
with the guns ninety percent of people
want stricter gun laws the
representatives are not
honoring the will of the people okay so
so real quick a couple points here one
the rape and incest case of abortion is
less than a tenth of a percentage point
okay okay so
now i don't disagree
you guys are doing you're debating on
row right so
what happens if roe gets overturned
it it's federally illegal but it takes
it back to the states right the states
get to decide so so you asked who
benefits from this
my stance would be the democracy
benefits for this because everybody
broadly agrees even ruth bader ginsburg
said that roe was wrongly decided that
it's a bad legal precedent it's a bad
case it's possibly the worst case in in
the history of the court the way it was
decided nowhere in the constitution does
it say anything about abortion and
that's what the court is there to do is
to interpret the laws right so what
happens if roe gets overturned then the
people can put it up for a vote they can
they can vote on it in congress right
you can vote to make it federally legal
why why is it that we have nine justices
in these cloaks and robes
reigning in their decision for the rest
of the country right
you asked who wins democracy wins if roe
gets overturned the people should stand
up and vote and i don't think democracy
is winning though is the thing i i think
i think it's it's the opposite i i think
we're again minority rule i get your
point and it's a good one and i i'd be
interested in reading that uh ruth bader
ginsburg quote because i think it's uh
it's it's a little deeper than that if
you could pull that up it'd be great um
but uh you bring it yes
you're right
if we can get if we can decide then as
if congress honored the will of the
people we would have a
democratic debate about the subject no
and i think i think that's absolutely
the point here is that it's not up to
these nine justices to have passed it in
the first place i think
and this speaks to a broader point of
the
the uh warping of the power that the
court has taken over that they just get
to decide off-whim what is and isn't
federal law right so it's like i i think
the best thing that we can do is have a
debate on this case and let the people
decide and as you say let congress agree
and listen to the will of the people
because we need to get back to some form
of that and give the people a voice
again
but there there their stance that it's
because it was never mentioned in the
constitution
doesn't mean they can rule on it uh
there's a lot of things that we have
laws on the books for that are not
mentioned in the constitution
transportation being one of them you
know what i'm saying and that we have
all kinds of federal regulations
regarding transportation so that's just
a weird take to have you know as a as a
supreme court justice well you know it's
not in there so we can't we have no no
no no say over it that's just weird i
don't know what you got pat yeah man
we've been i i don't know and by the way
here's here's uh uh here's what i'll
tell you when it comes down to guns
right okay i lived in california i lived
in texas and i lived in florida okay
in california i uh went to buy a gun and
i went and bought a
shotgun and a rifle maybe i bought a
semi i don't know what i bought over
there i bought a few things did a
background check took me 30 days to be
able to pick up my stuff i don't know
what the timeline was but it was a
minute i couldn't get it that day could
have been a week could have been 30 days
but i didn't leave with the stuff that i
bought that day fine
i went to texas in texas i uh went to a
store
and i bought an m4 i think about two of
them with the magazine with all the
stuff walk that five minutes later took
it to my car by the way you did my
interview i opened up to say you saw my
m16s you're like oh i see that guy
i've just
i've been shot in the military i've been
around won that big before so so i open
i'm like so here's what i did okay so
you come over here you know what i like
i like the fact that a person if you
don't want to have people
get guns early move to california or run
for office in your city and state and go
help change the laws okay go help in
that state get people behind you get a
strong argument get either get behind
somebody
or you go do it right if you think
a guy's going to be good against
desantis and you don't want the centers
to be reelected because you think
florida's going wrong direction either
find somebody that's going to beat the
santas or go move to california or new
york it's your choice by state right to
do that
with this argument here as well the same
same happens because
you know
those stories you read i mean
i've i've read both sides of the story
where hey look at all these great
innovators that their parents didn't get
an abortion they almost thought about
getting an abortion how about that how
about this person that you know was
going to be the president and parents at
one point thought about getting an
abortion and you read those stories like
what does the world look like without
those people oh my god couldn't even
imagine world without these guys so how
many stories are there that the mom and
the dad at one point thought about
getting an abortion and that person
ended up becoming great so who's right
on left and the right oh my god but this
person got raped in system okay so very
very so the exception to the rule which
is very small percentage they throw
those arguments up and it gets people
riled up right
so then you go to the other side and you
say okay your body your choice yeah how
come you didn't say that two years ago
how come you said that the last two
years which is kind of what you were
talking about why the hypocrisy so
you're then noticing the level of
hypocrisy on both sides
that comes out with arguments like this
and the lack of consistency
and you see leaks in arguments you only
want your body your choice when it
favors you but you don't want your body
your choice when it doesn't favor you
because you want everybody to take the
vaccine what happened to your body your
choice that's my body i don't want to
get the vaccine you better get around
you don't care about my health dude it's
my body i'm going to do whatever i want
to do my body why are you forcing me to
do it
and then the part that i have a
challenge with in regards to abortion is
i don't want to pay for it
if you went and got had sex unprotected
sex nobody told you to not use a condom
you chose i feel better when i have
unprotected sex no problem
it's your choice i don't care i'm just
not paying you abortion you pay for it
you want to get an abortion you're going
to pay for it i'm not going to pay for
it i didn't have sex that night i didn't
feel good when you had sex you had sex i
didn't feel good you had sex i felt good
for you i didn't get any of that joy why
am i getting the pain so let me get this
straight i didn't get that great feeling
of sex for you get for the last hour
long of it and i'm supposed to do the
bad you know to pay the price for the
bad part that you don't want to pay the
500 bucks whatever the numbers
i don't want to do that i don't want to
go through it um
everybody in their families says a
private abortion story i have some i'm
sure you have some and you have some you
see some folks who brag about how many
abortions they've had i also don't agree
with that this lady right here has got a
shirt on saying i've had 21 abortions
comedian a comedian got up and i don't
know who this comedian was about a year
and a half ago the girl with the curly
hair and said let me tell you how many
abortions i've had this is how many
abortions i've had matter of fact i'm
going to go get more abortions
it's not so that stuff is stupidity by
the way that's also the exception that's
not the majority so i'm not also putting
them as these guys are at fault no i'm a
reasonable enough of a person but i
think to leave it to the states
if guns are left to states
if this is left to state the way it
happened if you go look at the history
of
roe v wade is uh you know two supreme
court justices at the time
were either retiring uh tyler or they
were stepping away and this young
attorney comes in like really really
young and just somehow got this thing
through
and it would have never happened in this
case ever but this was a very
interesting unique situation that they
capitalized and
at the end of the day in regards to the
information being leaked and oh my god i
can't believe the information is leaked
and all that stuff and one side is
saying who cares about the person that
leaked the information i'm morgan
republicans are more targeting this than
protecting women's rights i'm sorry when
somebody leaked information to you on
the other side about hillary you were
pissed off to say why would you leak
this is irresponsible so then goes more
hypocrisy in the situation here at the
end of the day if it's 68
let's find out if it's 68
if it really is 68
maybe we're going to find out it ain't
68 percent maybe we're going to find out
those polls are full of [ __ ] maybe we're
going to find out more people are for
like unless if it's rape or incest or
this i i'm sorry i just don't support it
we don't know let them make that
decision for themselves and you know i
have my own position on this it's my
where i stand with this but it's
different for everybody else so i i you
know not whoopi joey comes out and joyce
says you know
a woman we should go on a sex strike
that's the bad news for you by the way
oh yeah we should go on a sex strike
okay don't give it up no no you can give
it up just use a damn condom when you
give it up why not she said that about
because of the abortion yeah well
condoms break it look i think i have bad
news for joy behar nobody's gonna be
upset if she goes on a sex strike nobody
that's a good point it is the question
is is it health care or is it not health
care and is it a society's
responsibility to
cover from their tax burden
health care
in general right
and you can make that argument that's an
argument to be had and
why we need better representation well
this goes back to your initial point
that it's not a black and white
situation there's so many gray areas
once you go here and you peel the onion
well you know what it's only in this
case well it's a rape it's an incest
well you get the life of the mother and
then what's up then this story and then
well actually it's been
is it six weeks is it 12 weeks it's just
such a complicated
situation that it takes such
grace to walk around and then obviously
if you say the wrong thing you're gonna
get canceled next thing you know joy
behar is doing a sex strike on you you
don't get any from joy catastrophic i'm
sure most single men in hollywood are
devastated right now because of her
going on a sex strike this is war on
women gays people of color you know what
they're saying if you let them do this
what happens next when they don't let
you have interracial marriages oh my god
now you're getting over dramatic on
interracial marriages who's gonna get
there and say we're not gonna do
interracial marriages but again
considering there's an interracial
marriage on the supreme court yeah at
the moment
but but listen at the end of the day
okay what's obama's famous words
after his first term what did he say
he says elections have what consequences
let's go buddy hey trump
may have
you can call him whatever you want but
if you're a republican
he got you a 6-3 advantage and that's
the biggest insurance policy that's
going to last
for 10 20 30 years it is rich of
mcconnell though you call the the the
politicization of the supreme court when
the reason there are there's a 6-3 is he
politicized the f out of the supreme
court yeah that's not the name i don't i
don't think anybody disputes that
mcconnell is an interesting cat himself
absolutely so interesting him and
schumer are probably part of the same
camp to me him schumer pelosi they're
they're part of the same thing i
understand that just another real quick
daily dose of irony uh who you know the
the left wants to fight to the death for
planned parenthood right and the largest
proportion of abortions in the country
are by black women right who is margaret
sanger the founder of planned parenthood
she was a well-known eugenicist who
wanted to prevent the birth of
uh mentally challenged people and blacks
in the country
i just think it's ironic i've heard that
argument i don't think that's entirely
accurate but i i've heard i've heard
that argument before and i think that's
tyler gets his information for some from
certain sources no no but nothing he
said isn't necessarily true but i think
i don't think it's the entire truth
again it's we all we tend to as you know
especially today when politics has
become religion
glom on to one part of the argument and
hold on to that when it's like yeah but
also this you know what i mean is putin
evil well not to not to his motherland
he's not right so
what's what's the what's the answer we
don't have it here at the pbd podcast
but this was great discourse folks i'm
curious where you stand comment below
i'd love to actually read your
commentary see what you stand with this
last topic before we wrap up is musk
okay let's wrap up with musk here how
can we do this podcast without talking
about this guy here right so musk
goes after aoc nbc and pretty much
everybody in the same week can you pull
up the nbc tweet
that's the one i want to read page five
i'll read this to you guys and then
he'll put it up so you can see it elon
musk slams nbc defends gop after msnbc
anchor calls him
petulant is am i saying it properly the
pronunciation okay so this is a newsweek
story illama slammed nbc on monday after
an anchor affiliated the media outlet
called and petulant and criticized the
far right of the republican party the
tesla ceo who recently purchased twitter
hit back after msnbc host mehdi hassan
warned
that his new uh influence over the
social media platform may amplify
neo-nazi voices within the gop we are
living through an unspeakably dangerous
moment the pro-q on pro-neo-nazi faction
of the republican party is poised to
expand dramatically come to midterms if
that happens we may look back on this as
a pivotal moment when the petulant and
not so bright billionaire casually
bought one of the most influential
messaging machines and just
handed it to the far right musk
initially responded by tweeting that nbc
is basically saying republicans or nazis
but in a separate post he said the
following if you want to show them the
tweet if you have it he slammed the news
platform by saying can you make that a
little bit bigger nbc basically saying
republicans are nazis then he turns
around and says that same organization
that covered up hunter biden's laptop
story had harvey weinstein's story
leaked and killed it and built matt
lauer his rape office lovely people do
you imagine that he's got a point
i'm no musk stan but you know i don't
think he's nearly as as dangerous as
people make him out to be hassan is an
agitator uh on the network you know this
is not the first sort of crazy thing he
said um
is he is elon musk a pest sure is he is
he is he dumb no
um i think personally twitter stands to
get better under his leadership
personally i i could be wrong
um
you know the arguments made that it you
know oh it's a private company they can
edit whoever they want if he wants to
make it into more of a public square
where any information is is spewed
around there
let's see what happens you know let's
see what happens we're seeing what
happens
before you know you get the russian bots
off of there maybe you've got a platform
and i think that might be one of the
best things yeah that was the greatest
what was the conversation you had uh
yesterday regarding uh what elon musk is
looking to do
yeah he's he's raising money left and
right and and in rounds of 100 million i
got a call
and uh i i'm telling you right now i
predict
twitter's right now worth what 40 some
billion dollars can you pull out what
twitter's worth today should i what's
that on twitter today
if you can get it the rounds are 100
million uh if you can get in and there's
not a lot of people that are sitting on
100 million dollars of cash that's the
challenge market cap 38 billion dollars
okay here's what i'll tell you
twitter
ran by elon musk will be a trillion
dollar company within three to five
years and that's the latest which means
and by the way this is my opinion
okay this is if you do it you lose money
that's your risk this is my opinion
i think this is a trillion dollar
company
um i think that 40 goes to a trillion
that's 25 x you put a million bucks
you're gonna make 25 you put 10 million
bucks you're gonna make 250. you put 100
grand it's gonna be two and a half
million dollar investment because if
facebook's worth a trillion
if google's worth the trillion if
amazon's worth two if you know i think
apple's worth three whatever the number
is this is gonna be a trillion dollar
company because the people that ran
twitter they don't know how to make
money and elon knows how to make money
he's gonna create different chips
whether it's gonna be you on a blue chip
to get rid of the bots 4.99 a month you
want an additional you know benefit to
do this 19.99 a month and you want the
ultimates it's 100 bucks a month he's
going to make money off of twitter and
he's going to bring so many different
ideas that nobody's even thinking about
most people think tesla is a car company
it's a battery company that's why he
doesn't like selling tesla because he
knows tesla's going to be a 10 trillion
dollar company and he knows he's going
to be the first trillionaire in the
world he's probably two to five years
away from being a trillionaire this
guy's going to be a trillionaire we're
going to have a trillionaire within the
next 24 to 60 months but twitter by this
guy running it i have a feeling this
thing's gonna go to the roof
because he ain't gonna slow down fyi
more and more and more i listen to him
he may be the most annoying
person
to anybody that doesn't like freedom of
speech to anybody who loves control
because you can't do nothing to this guy
okay bill maher comes out
and says
the argument to me is has twitter failed
in setting themselves up in the past as
the judge of what can go out there and i
would say yes you have you failed when
you threw the new york post off of
twitter for talking about hunter biden's
emails and it turned out to be a real
story you failed when you said we
couldn't read about whether kovid had
come from a lab you failed twitter you
failed this is not a republican saying
this
this is a liberal who's probably never
voted for a republican in his life bill
maher saying this a comment like that so
what's starting to happen yesterday
we're having dinner and kai is talking
about churchill
okay he says you know in in uk no one's
lost more elections no politicians lost
more elections in their career than
churchill yeah crazy story yeah but then
he says you know what happened at one
point because he was part of the
democratic party is who he was okay
that's what churchill is when you read a
story he says at one point the people
that he was a part of flipped and they
went crazy so what does churchill do he
says dude i didn't sign up for this
i'm about freedom i'm about this i'm
about that i don't know what just
happened to you democrats but i'm not
about that you're changing the party i'm
going over here they hated him for it he
says i didn't change you guys change
democratic party's changing bill maher
said those very words i haven't changed
i haven't changed you've changed so bill
maher said what churchill said years ago
years ago churchill said that before
bill maher said it except when churchill
said that he didn't tweet it out right
go back you know for whatever reason he
didn't get the time to tweet it out
moral the story is the following elon
musk
is probably the most scary man to the
people of the left and progressives
aoc goes to sleep every night everyone
has nightmares or dreams she goes to
sleep every night about a man named elon
musk she has nightmares about him
every flipping night and it's non-stop
it's going to keep happening because
this guy's not going to slow down he's
not going to be somebody that's going to
sit on the sideline saying okay let me
take it a little bit easy this week no
you say something to him he's coming
back at you and he's got a bigger mic
and that mike is twitter so and what did
elon say to to back to aoc in a tweet
and when she's basically was complaining
about the billionaire class you showed
that tweet through her
thing back at her yeah he said you know
i was talking about mark zuckerberg and
he said well you know stop hitting on me
i'm really shy
he's a troll a total multi-billionaire
powerful man ridiculous
troll
um and he's only gonna get stronger he's
just gonna get stronger this guy is not
going to slow down he's going to
continue
yeah he's going to continue more and
more and more is that what it is stop
hitting on me i'm really shy gotta love
that
gotta love that so anyway she said that
to some one of her trolls too at one
point i think he was throwing her is
that what it was ah
somebody was bitching about it
and she's like uh you know stop flirting
who's elon gonna date next he's done
with the alien girl grimes who's next
for sure not gonna be done with amber
hurt exactly ain't gonna be 100
no i i think he's correct
marjorie taylor green yeah
no you can dream tyler i think he's
going to date somebody you least expect
that he's going to date i think elon is
a very different kind of guy he's a
hollande generation type of guy but
he'll be the first trillionaire the way
he's going right now so folks if you
hate billionaires i don't know what
you're going to do to trillionaires
because one is around the corner
this has been a blast bro awesome great
it's great having you on thank you matt
uh tomorrow gsp what time so everybody
knows that 3 30 to 3 30 tomorrow gsp
will be on the podcast come ready we may
do some callers and by the way we may be
giving away
auctioning off maybe through super chat
and maybe something we may do a signed
ufc glove if you're a big gsp fan put in
your calendar tomorrow at the podcast
we'll see you guys there take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
you